on the 13th of october 1989 the town of
danner wisconsin was shaken by a seismic
event unlike anything they'd ever
experienced this might have been written
off as an earthquake where not for one
disturbing factor the ground shaking
event was accompanied by a huge spike of
radioactivity with the strange
phenomenon happening a month before the
berlin wall was torn down during a
period of the cold war that historians
call the year of crisis it's easy to
understand why the people of danner
immediately assumed the worst but the
huge eruption they felt wasn't the
result of a nuclear bomb going off the
scp foundation was alerted to the event
in danner when they picked up a series
of radio transmissions coming from just
outside the town when they arrived they
found something incredible like
something out of a sci-fi movie standing
at the quake's epicenter was a creature
that looked to be from another world
standing two meters tall and weighing
almost 300 kilograms the being was green
and brown in color with a bulky humanoid
body its head was a different story
though and resembled a gigantic house
fly with a proboscis and huge
stereoscopic eyes surprisingly the
strange creature did not immediately go
on a rampage instead the being
designated scp-2273
appeared to be exhausted injured and
extremely malnourished it offered no
resistance at all to the foundation
containment team and it was taken to
site 17 without conflict while the scp
foundation is no stranger to visitors
from other worlds there was something
especially unusual about this supposed
alien invader the doctors who examined
the creature and treated its injuries
found an appendage that seemed to
function as an organic radio transmitter
and large open wounds on its shoulder
blades and forearms where further
appendages had been ripped off
additionally while its insect-like
exoskeleton was mostly a uniform green
and brown pattern the creature's upper
arms and torso were dotted with a
variety of scars and markings that on
closer inspection looked like military
badges was this some kind of wounded
intergalactic soldier who had been
stranded on earth if it was then how
were the organic badges on this alien's
exoskeleton a near-perfect match to
military badges worn by soldiers in the
soviet union even if they did reference
a unit that didn't officially exist
within the soviet army the scientists
were sure this alien wasn't an alien at
all underneath its exoskeleton was a
non-anomalous human being if that was
true then this was even more terrifying
than an extraterrestrial visitor the
scientists were sure that the ussr had
developed a new kind of organic armor
and this anomaly showing up in wisconsin
was the result of a test on u.s soil
that had gone wrong if that was the case
then there was no telling how many more
of these exoskeletons were out there and
would need to be contained the
foundation had to act quickly and find
out more while
scp-2273 was recovering they called in
dr friedrich an on-site psychologist who
could speak several languages including
russian dr friedrich would be tasked
with interrogating the scp on his
origins and the nature of the suit the
interview was conducted via am radio
from a separate observation chamber as
the biological transmitter seemed to be
scp-2273's only method of communication
the interview began with dr friedrich
speaking to
scp-2273 in russian only for 2273 to
respond that dr friedrich's accent was
atrocious and requesting he used german
instead
scp-2273 who according to the organic
military patches on his body was named
major alexei belatrov initially resisted
being interviewed he believed that he
was a prisoner of war being held by the
american military according to him he
had been in the middle of battle and
that the americans had killed his men
and left him for dead in the wilderness
nothing that dr friedrich told him that
there was no war or that the foundation
was not affiliated with the u.s
government could convince him otherwise
and he refused to talk further before a
second interview was conducted bellatrov
was given an old copy of the level 1
researcher general debrief as a way of
helping him further understand the
nature of the foundation and his
containment belatrov was more
cooperative after that though the
realization that he would most likely be
kept in containment for the rest of his
life caused him great distress and he
was unwilling to speak to dr friedrich
for another three days dr friedrich
didn't give up though and when bellatra
finally opened up to the doctor he began
to tell him more and more bellatroph
told the doctor that when he was a child
russia was hit by an american nuclear
warhead and that the soviet union
immediately retaliated the resulting
nuclear conflict which belatrov called
the war to end the world caused massive
devastation and left most of the planet
dangerously irradiated that is why he
had the exoskeleton it was to shield him
from the radiation and allow him to
survive above ground unfortunately
bellatrov knew very little about how the
suit was made or how it worked saying
that it was built by the engineers and
that it grew naturally over a period of
several years but belatrov hadn't made
the decision himself it was his parents
who had volunteered him as a test
subject for the exoskeleton suit program
when he was still young hoping it would
give him a better chance at survival the
process of bonding the exoskeleton to
the human body was extremely painful but
according to balotrov its advantages far
outweighed the pain the suit not only
helped him survive in a nuclear
wasteland but made him a better soldier
the suit allowed him to lift and carry
up to 1200 kilograms gave him
stereoscopic vision and the organic
radio transmitter allowed him to
communicate with other soldiers across
long distances as well as listen in on
encrypted enemy transmissions the wounds
on his shoulders and arms where it
looked like appendages had been ripped
down where where his weapons and supply
packs had previously been mounted
bellatrov had been stationed with his
men in the area he was discovered when
they were attacked by american soldiers
the soldiers had ripped off bellatrop's
weapons and supply pack and did the same
to all his men as well they were all
shot with bellatroph being spared for
the moment only because the americans
had identified him as the commanding
officer suddenly there was a bright
flash of light and the american soldiers
vanished not only that but the landscape
changed where there had been a
post-nuclear wasteland before now there
were lush green trees injured and
disoriented bellatrov began sending
distress signals only to have those
signals intercepted by the scp
foundation the most interesting part of
belatrov's story as far as the
foundation was concerned came during his
fourth interview when dr friedrich asked
him about the engineers who had designed
the
suit in beltrav's own words they weren't
truly known to man until the years of
the great war and the revolution the
french found them in buried cities where
the western allies were digging their
trenches eventually they were made to
build weapons for the war by both sides
by his description these engineers
didn't sound human but they were by no
means unknown to the scp foundation
belatrov described the engineers as
humanoid nocturnal covered in fur and
possessing technology and intelligence
far beyond that of any human those
familiar with the foundation's history
might already know the engineers by
their foundation designation of
scp-1000 or their more commonly known
name bigfoot a quick rundown
scp-1000 are a species of intelligent
humanoid primates that lived alongside
humanity in highly advanced cities until
their own technology was turned against
them not only were their cities wiped
off the face of the earth but 70 percent
of their population was slaughtered and
the survivors were driven mad to the
point that their mental faculties were
no higher than those of a chimpanzee or
gorilla the scp foundation is tasked
with keeping them away from human
contact in fear of what the creatures
would be able to do to humanity if they
ever regained their memories and full
mental function and rumors have been
spread about them possessing deadly
anomalous properties but evidently the
destruction of the scp-1000 species
never occurred in bellatrop's universe
or if it did it wasn't nearly as
complete in that timeline humanity
regained contact with scp-1000 after
discovering their underground cities
sometime during world war one after this
discovery both allied and access powers
began recruiting them to build weapons
and their weapons played a role in both
the russian revolution and the second
world war it was because of these
technological advantages that the cold
war escalated into what would become the
war to end all wars both sides were
armed with not only nuclear warheads but
highly advanced radiation-proof
exoskeleton armor that allowed the
conflict to continue even after the
total destruction of the planet while
the humans fought above ground life
continued as normal for scp-1000 in
their underground cities as veletrov
noted they never wore the armor
themselves as they had no need to
venture above ground only soldiers wear
armor and this is not their war
bellatroph continued to adjust to life
in containment and sitting for regular
interviews with dr friedrich he was
given the rations provided for humanoid
anomalies but in much larger quantities
as the suit required him to eat around 8
000 calories a day to keep it
functioning bellatrov also began taking
advantage of his ability to access the
foundation's library he would often read
or listen to classical music
particularly by the russian composer
tchaikovsky he seemed especially fond of
reading the time machine by h.g wells no
surprise given he was able to directly
relate to the experience of living
through an apocalypse and being
transported to a strange timeline with
no way to return home but with little
else to occupy his time bellatrov began
to displace symptoms consistent with
post-traumatic stress disorder reporting
in his now regular interviews with dr
friedrich that he was constantly
reliving memories of the battles he'd
fought and the lives he had taken in
combat the suit was making the problems
worse too it seemed it was as if he
could never forget as one of its
features was an ability to store and
replay memories this feature was
intended as a strategic aid that would
allow commanding officers to more
effectively gather and process
information about their surroundings but
outside of combat this only served to
force bellatrov into reliving his most
painful memories again and again every
night as he tried to sleep you would see
the faces of his men their weapons torn
from their exoskeletons laying in the
dirt after being gunned down by the
enemy like many veterans bellatrov was
being hit all at once with the harsh
realities of war now that his brain
wasn't solely focused on keeping him
alive it had time to process all the
horrors he'd experienced he told dr
friedrich i trained alongside these men
for years before they put us back on the
surface since we were all young children
we were brothers and i gave them the
order to surrender and got them killed i
should have died with them while the
story of
scp-2273 ends here the story of alexi
belatrov scp-2273-1
continues in 2018 belatrov was allowed
passage to volgrad russia as part of an
anomaly reintegration program while he
was unable to secure employment within
the russian government as he had hoped
he eventually was taken in by a
monastery and continued to write letters
to dr friedrich until friedrich's
eventual death from lymphoma-related
complications there's plenty more on the
monastery the anomaly reintegration
program and what happened to major
bellatrov when he returned to russia but
that will have to be a story for another
day
the year was 1857 and the second opium
war was raging between china and the
combined forces of the english and
french it was one of the many bloody
colonial wars fought over resources like
tea sugar and the intoxicating opium
poppy it was a war fought by peasants
and noblemen alike one of these
aristocratic soldiers was the noble lord
theodore thomas blackwood the
quintessential english gentleman and
explorer while his fellow soldiers
cowered behind cover lord blackwood
charged into the fray shouldering his
rifle and firing his pistol into the
crowd of opposing soldiers it was the
battle of canton one of the most crucial
battles of the entire conflict the
french and english were laying siege to
the city of canton also known as
guangzhou to prove their military
dominance and capture an important
chinese government official lord
blackwood led the charge on horseback
every bullet seemed to find the heart of
a foe he was a true hero among men a
gentleman warrior with class refinement
and style and it would be thanks to his
expert leadership and marksmanship on
the field that the allied european
forces won the battle decisively lord
theodore thomas blackwood is a name that
deserves to be counted among lord
horatio nelson sir francis bacon and sir
walter raleigh in addition to being a
skilled and honorable fighter lord
blackwood is a consummate explorer
naturalist and frontiersman during his
heyday he traveled perhaps further than
any man across the known and unknown
corners of the globe he made scientific
biological and anthropological
discoveries that should have reset the
course of society forever and yet you
won't find any records in the history
books of lord theodore thomas blackwood
nor will you find any grand oil
paintings or dedicated wings in british
museums this is because lord theodore
thomas blackwood is a four and a half
inch telepathic neon sea slug and he's
known to the scp foundation as scp-1860
well he would never admit to it lord
blackwood belongs to the species
nembrotha kubaryana also known as the
variable neon slug he's kept in a
standard aquarium in a foundation
containment site and is physically no
different to any other member of his
species what makes lord blackwood unique
is his powerful telepathic abilities
specifically the power to communicate by
speaking directly into people's minds
and what's more he's extremely talkative
but to what extent is anything that this
anomalous sea slug says true or is he
just like scp-082
fernand the cannibal a creative and
pathological liar it isn't committed to
record how exactly the foundation
discovered lord blackwood perhaps a
local aquarium worker worried they were
going insane when they heard the voice
of a 19th century english nobleman
ringing in their ears whenever they were
cleaning algae out of the tank maybe
lord blackwood was found by scp
foundation divers who are constantly
combing the ocean for anomalous
creatures and activity what we do know
is that lord blackwood is an incredibly
strange and mysterious individual he
claims to have visited locations all
around the world and encountered rare
societies and creatures the foundation
was skeptical about a number of lord
blackwood's more outlandish claims on
account of him being a sea slug but he
does appear to have the knowledge to
back up his supposed experience
interviews with lord blackwood have
shown that he's extremely knowledgeable
in the areas of geography zoology botany
archaeology anthropology and linguistics
relating to his claim regions of
exploration as well as more esoteric
fields such as obscure mythology
mysticism and cryptozoology in other
words if lord blackwood hadn't gone on
his escapades around the globe
throughout history how would he have
come to possess this wide variety of
information the foundation was getting
frustrated and began to probe further
into the personal life of the most
interesting gastropod in containment
lord blackwood under questioning was
always polite and amicable with
foundation staff he seemed to display no
real knowledge of the fact that he
himself was a sea slug going as far to
accuse other people of being crazy or
drunk when they brought the fact up to
him while none of lord blackwood's tall
tales ever extend past the year 1910. he
told fanciful stories of exploring the
americas and of his involvement in the
second opium war on the side of the
english naturally the foundation wanted
proof when they pressured lord blackwood
on this something even stranger happened
he gave it the lord told his
interviewers that he would happily
donate his collection to them if it gave
them cause to believe what he was saying
he gave the baffled foundation
researchers the address of a cottage in
england where they could find the
secrets to his bizarre and mysterious
past and local agents in the area
followed up on the information upon
investigation foundation field agents
did indeed find the cottage that lord
blackwood had specified it was being
maintained by an extremely old woman
when questioned about her presence there
she said that she was keeping the house
for lord blackwood and gave no more
useful information incidentally it
appears that this singular purpose was
all that this old woman was living for
she abruptly passed away from heart
failure five days after the foundation
commandeered the cottage whether
anything truly anomalous caused this we
still do not know at first the cottage
seemed normal until the field agents
discovered a secret basement housing
lord blackwood's collection they were
amazed at what they saw the basement
consisted of zoological and botanical
specimens over 3000 artifacts a library
containing over 5 000 items and a
functioning 1800 scientific laboratory
it took about three weeks for foundation
agents working round the clock in shifts
to remove all the items from lord
blackwood's mysterious collection and
what they found raised even more
questions the collection included but
was no means limited to 116 unknown
species of plants 107 unknown species of
insects 28 unknown species of lizards 23
unknown species of fish 14 unknown
species of amphibians 12 unknown species
of mammals fossils pertaining to 8
unknown species of dinosaur fossils
pertaining to 12 unknown species of
prehistoric mammal and artifacts
belonging to 29 unknown indigenous
societies that's a lot of unknowns but
wait there's more his collection also
contained a collection of seemingly
unknown firearms including three wide
bore muskets marked as dr bt moths
effective particle destabilizers
detailed globes of mercury venus mars
and the galilean moons accompanied by
notes detailing possible paths of
surface exploration a heavily modified
carriage containing instruments of
unknown purpose a note attached to the
door reads on the fritz speak with henry
and a highly dangerous and seemingly
anomalous machine that killed four
foundation field agents before it was
destroyed on site and when questioned
about this little fiasco lord blackwood
responded i did warn you to be careful
around my collection that bloody thing
nearly took my head off back in 97 when
i found it however there was one thing
recovered from lord blackwood's
collection that was perhaps more
interesting than all the others 35
handwritten journals containing
recordings of events described by lord
blackwood in this grangio's tall tales
to the foundation researchers the
accounts are generally identical to the
stories he had told save for some slight
variations and exaggerations on the part
of blackwood in the retelling most
interestingly of all all of these
journals have been dated to the
appropriate time period of the events
described by foundation scientists while
his stories are too numerous to all be
shared here there's one that perfectly
sums them all up lord blackwood's
account of a possible encounter with
scp-1000
also known as bigfoot in seattle during
the mid-1800s lord blackwood seeking to
explore the so-called new world of north
america embarked with an assistant and
an indigenous american guide to the
pacific northwest in search of the
legendary sasquatch the trio was headed
for mount rainier
then known as tahoma during the journey
lord blackwood found a young fox caught
in a trap that had been set by a local
tribe he took sympathy on the animal and
freed it allowing it to run away to
safety that night he and his assistant
met up with the rest of his guide's
tribe and they settled down for the
evening however things took a disastrous
turn when the camp was raided by a rival
tribe almost everyone was slaughtered in
the process and lord blackwood and his
two companions were hauled away by the
enemy tribe for a sinister purpose
sacrifice to a violent local deity as it
turns out the creature that this tribe
worshipped was the very same one lord
blackwood and the others were trying to
find a particularly large and aggressive
sasquatch each night a different
sacrifice was made to the sasquatch the
victim would be placed near a forest
clearing while the tribe played a primal
song and the sasquatch would emerge from
the trees to devour its prey
the first night it ate the assistant the
next night it ate the guide and then it
became time for the sacrifice of lord
blackwood himself as blackwood was
presented for sacrifice he accepted his
fate but instead of the sasquatch a
legion of woodland animals emerged from
the trees foxes elks raccoons and more
themselves painted with tribal symbols
the animals seemed to be on lord
blackwood's side and attacked the
tribe's people who had been holding him
captive giving blackwood the chance to
flee into the forest during the chaos
later these same animals would find
blackwood again and present him with
things his captors had stolen from him
and elder fox also gave him a letter
proclaiming him a knight of their people
now he was allowed safe passage back to
a nearby settlement at which point he
wrote to his financiers back in england
explaining the situation and asking for
more money to perform further
expeditions into the tahoma region the
whole incident had only increased his
thirst for adventure and exploration
whether this tale is actually true or
just a bizarre colonial fantasy from the
pathological mind of a telepathic sea
slug we may never know but it doesn't
make it any less interesting to this day
lord blackwood continues to be a
perplexing but fascinating anomaly he
may not be the most dangerous and he may
not be the most useful either but
there's no denying that perhaps we'd all
like to sit next to his tank for a
couple hours one day and hear him spin a
good yarn over a warm cup of tea
welcome back comrade the case of
scp-2270
also known as major alexi bellatrov has
sparked your imagination and you need to
know more but even if you're not
familiar with the major his story all
you need to know is that it's one of war
tragedy and alternate dimensions he
first appeared in the town of danner
wisconsin on the 13th of october 1989
during an unprecedented seismic event
when he was first discovered the
foundation researchers assumed that he
was an extraterrestrial being on account
of his advanced organic exoskeleton in a
surprising move for such an imposing
creature belatrov gave himself up to
foundation agents without a fight major
belatrov was then impounded in
foundation containment site-17 where he
was interrogated thoroughly over a
series of interviews the foundation
ascertained that belatrov came from an
alternate timeline where russia and the
u.s are locked in a so-called war to end
the world thanks to advanced military
technology given to them by
scp-1000 bellatrov had nearly escaped
execution at the hands of american
soldiers and appeared in our timeline
now he is a prisoner of the advanced
suit that formerly kept him alive but
his story isn't over the last remnant of
a cold war turned hot has plenty left to
teach us something that you need to
understand about the scp foundation
before we go any further is that it
doesn't only exist in every nation
across the globe it also exists in every
splinter reality across the multiverse
and these splinter realities offer a
countless multitude of tales of
different places different people and
different times today's tale concerns
major bellatrov's future in a universe
where the secrecy of the foundation is
broken and the anomalous world needs to
find a way to fit in with our own the
year was 2018 like many humanoid
anomalies that the foundation was
holding in this timeline bellatrov was
released from containment he was no
longer an scp he was now a mere person
of interest free to move around as he
pleased but this didn't mean bellatrov
was about to enjoy a quiet life on easy
street he was still an interdimensional
refugee from a broken alternate world
thankfully there was a certain group
willing to help the mana charitable
foundation this anomalous charity has
been involved in a number of strange
cases investigated by the foundation
before and now they were going to lend a
hand to major bellatroph thanks to their
anomaly reintegration project mana was
able to transport bellatrov back to his
home of vulgrad in russia there he
became something of a national celebrity
making headlines across the country
sitting down for interviews on every
russian talk show and even being offered
book deals but as a former military man
bellatrov was eager to return to
government life and run for a government
position however this ambition didn't go
very far belatrov was rejected by all
the government bodies he applied to even
vladimir putin wasn't eccentric enough
to want an insecticide cyborg from
another dimension in his cabinet
bellatrov endured a rough two years in
volgrav he was treated more like a
sideshow freak than a human being people
didn't want to rent apartments to him
and he was never able to find permanent
employment even entry-level jobs
rejected him nobody wanted to get food
served to them by what looked to be a
7-foot monster and he seemed equally
ill-suited to help russian women find
the right perfume in department stores
in april of 2020 bellatrov had finally
had enough he contacted the mana
charitable foundation once again and
asked to be relocated they told him that
some religious institutions in the area
including the eastern clockwork orthodox
church were accepting and housing
anomalous refugees not long after this
belatrov truly fell off of the scp
foundation's radar but one former
foundation operative was well aware of
major bellatrov's fate it's 2021. dr
friedrich the site-17 anomaly
psychologist who'd conducted all the
initial interviews with belatrov all the
way back in 1989
started receiving letters from him there
was no indication as to his true
location and they appeared to have been
handled by a mana charitable foundation
mail carrier in russia but dr friedrich
was happy to hear from an old friend
nonetheless due to a career of working
near highly radioactive anomalies like
bellatrov dr friedrich was suffering
from terminal lymphoma it seemed almost
like an act of divine providence that
belatrov's letters would come to him so
close to the end the two began a
correspondence and it was only after dr
friedrich's eventual death that the
letters came to the scp foundation's
attention it was from this final
correspondence that the foundation was
able to answer the big question whatever
happened to major alexi bellatrov in his
first letter to dr friedrich bellatrov
thanked him profusely he knew that dr
friedrich had been a crucial part of him
gaining freedom from the foundation and
credited the therapeutic techniques
taught to him by dr friedrich with
keeping him alive and sane to this day
bellatrov expressed a mix of amazement
at this brave new world and a sense of
profound weariness as a man eternally
locked into a weapon of war he felt
unsuited to a world in peacetime he
almost missed the scorched irradiated
russia of his home dimension but most of
all he missed site 17. he missed dr
friedrich he missed some of his fellow
anomalies like scp-50
the teleporting man and
scp-163 the spacecraft he even missed
the simplicity of being contained he
hoped that dr friedrich would write back
in his second letter bellatrov began
detailing his experience with the
eastern clockwork orthodox church
despite growing up in a highly atheistic
communist environment belatrov became
enamored with the ways of the church he
found them to be highly accepting of him
in spite of his unfortunate
circumstances they displayed a freedom
in their faith that beletrov had never
encountered before and he was eager to
be a part of it with the help of dr
friedrich belladrov was also sending
letters to some of his fellow freed
anomalies he signed off by saying that
he had even started praying something
he'd never considered before the next
letter sent in 2027 struck a much more
somber tone it was sent shortly after
bellatrov discovered dr friedrich's
diagnosis he wanted to return and see
the doctor one more time but the mana
charitable foundation wouldn't allow him
to return to site 17 believing he had
been abused during his time there
belodrov gave frederick his prayers and
well wishes and asked for a number
through which he could contact his
ailing old friend by the time the next
letter arrived in 2034 belatrov had
become a fully fledged member of the
eastern clockwork orthodox church he
referred to the other monks at the
monastery as his brothers and sisters he
seemed to have finally found a true home
there and the others fondly referred to
him by the nickname father anvil but the
true heart of the letter is bellatrov's
deep concern for dr friedrich's health
notably in this letter he often refers
to dr friedrich by his first name thomas
as though to emphasize the urgency of
the message after the deaths of several
of the anomalies that beletrov
considered friends he stated that he
couldn't handle losing anyone else his
letter ends with a poignant passage you
may be unmarried dr friedrich but you
are not unloved you have to be strong
for me you have to be strong for
yourself if you're ever worried that you
cannot find the strength to continue
think of the garden you'll plant this
spring i'd like to share gardening
photos with you again not many of my
brothers and sisters here appreciate the
simple beauty of a flower bed or the
effort that goes into growing a patch of
vegetables it's a beauty i'd like to
continue to share trust in the power of
our lord thomas and trust in the power
of modern medicine god is smiling on you
please be strong with love and prayers
alexey bellatrov this letter arrived on
the 15th of february 2034. sadly dr
friedrich had already passed away four
days earlier he never got to see alexis
final letter and it truly was his final
letter with nobody left for him in the
world major bellatrov stops sending any
correspondence what we know about the
final years of belatrov's life all comes
from a few scattered journal entries
translated from russian after his
passing they provide clues as to the
kind of life he lived during the 29
years the foundation could not account
for his whereabouts and his actions the
first entry written on january 7th 2035
paints a grim picture of bellatrov
feeling broken and isolated in the
monastery he wrote
is the day that our monastery celebrates
the birth of our lord however i feel no
desire to celebrate all of my friends in
this world are dead my brothers and
sisters are partaking in some
celebration outside my dormitory all of
the required ceremonies are complete
neither they nor whatever is happening
out there with light in mind
bellatrov also wrote about losing the
comfort he once had in his faith and his
doubts about whether he would be able to
recapture that comfort but he had
survived greater traumas than this and
he would continue to press on as the
months turned to years and the years
turned to decades bellatrov climbed
through the ranks of the monastery
seeing as the eastern clockwork orthodox
church practically worshiped the
concepts of industrialization and
mechanization the fact that belatrov was
permanently encased in a biomechanical
exoskeleton probably made him seem even
more pious to his holy brethren the
final piece of evidence collected by the
foundation into the life and times of
alexi belatrov came just over 20 years
later in a final address written to
comfort his followers in preparation for
his own death belatrov recounted the
details of his own life being born into
a world of fire death and mushroom
clouds then his life being suddenly
saved by forces beyond his control only
to place him into containment for almost
30 years it was only after accepting the
teachings of the church and accepting
the clockwork goddess that he felt he
was truly free from his past in this
final note belotrov lay out some of the
teachings of his new religion the belief
in a great mechanized goddess who
planned all of reality according to
belatrov everything in her design fits
together perfectly like cogs in a
machine turning and twisting in unison
to create an ideal world he hoped to be
forgiven for the many violent sins he
committed in his military life and that
his contributions to this new world were
valuable at the very end of his address
belatrov wrote i do not believe that my
time in this world is much longer
brothers and sisters when my time of
judgment comes do not mourn me i would
rather you remember these words the
goddess is most pleased with those who
see kind non-violent resolution to their
problems
because a machine whose gears grind
against each other is a machine that
cannot work see truth but also
compassion the words are only words seek
out truth within them god bless you all
father anvil a month after authoring
this statement records indicate that
alexey belatrov was found dead in his
room having passed away peacefully in
his sleep from natural causes he lived a
warrior's life but died a humble
priest's death the true tragedy in the
strange life of major alexei belatrov is
how little choice he had in his
circumstances but thanks to this tale we
know he did what he could with the life
he was given his remains lay within the
graveyard at the eastern clockwork
orthodoxy monastery where he spent the
last years of his life with a life as
difficult as his own we can only imagine
he's glad to finally rest
[Music]
some of the anomalies the scp foundation
deals with are dangerous with the most
powerful able to end all life and even
reality as we know it others pose no
threat at all and seem content to simply
exist still others are something else
entirely
scp-4999 is a humanoid entity though its
appearance seems to fluctuate between
manifestations with the only unchanging
detail being that it always is dressed
in dark formal wear originally thought
by many to be an urban legend local
tales of
scp-4999 are what initially tipped the
foundation off to its existence and
further research indicates that there
are accounts that may be referring to
the appearances of 49.99 throughout
recorded history strangest of all though
is the consistency with which it appears
or rather the consistent situations and
types of people it appears to from the
data available it seems that scp-4999
only appears to people in a very
specific type of need as you'll see in
the case of a subject named alex
hereford and the fateful night he
experienced
the road was slippery and alex was
driving too fast he knew this of course
but it's a different matter altogether
to know a thing and to care about it
rain hammered on the front windshield
the weak headlights of his 2005 honda
civic barely punching into the thick
black knight ahead of him winding
through the mountainside the road was
mostly empty save for the very
occasional twin beams of light blazing
past him due to his high speed it was
hard to hear the honking of angry horns
over the heavy pounding of the rain then
it happened in a way alex knew it was
inevitable his tread worn wheels finally
lost contact with the ground thick layer
of rainwater between them and asphalt
betraying his speeding vehicle's grip on
the road and sending it careening out of
control he had expected fear but instead
felt nothing really a slight sense of
anticipation like wincing right before a
punch lands in that childhood game of
hitting each other on the arm it wasn't
that the world had slowed down but
perhaps his brain was simply working at
a much greater velocity now recognizing
its own impending death his speed of
thought seemed magnified to the point of
slowing his perception down he heard of
soldiers in war zones experiencing the
same phenomenon as they felt sure that
in the next few seconds they'd be dead
alex wondered would he smash into a tree
go off a cliff's edge he could hardly
see the forest or the terrain beyond in
the thick rain in the dark of the
mountain though he traveled this road a
million times before he had no idea
where he actually was tonight he
supposed it wouldn't really matter which
it was as usual his thoughts turned to
her or rather they had simply run their
course and returned to the one place
they always did it wasn't like there
were many other people to think about in
alex's mostly empty life there was and
always had been since the moment he'd
met her mostly just her but even alex's
heightened state of mind couldn't delay
the inevitable for long it would be a
cliff after all alex thought curiously
catching a glimpse of town lights far
away and below the car spun 180 degrees
out into empty air then came crashing
down with a horrible roar of shattered
glass and tearing metal as it tumbled
down the hillside even over the
torrential downpour the noise of alex's
crash was significant had anyone been
around to hear it finally after over a
hundred feet down a steep incline the
car smashed into a single thick oak tree
bringing the disaster to an end as if on
cue the rain began to let up slowly at
first then all of a sudden in that
peculiar way that northwest torrential
downpours tend to do as if the sky had
at last finished emptying itself all at
once inside the shattered vehicle alex
was incredibly alive at least for the
time being the airbag deployment had
spared his face the worst of it and the
sturdy aluminum frame of the vehicle had
given its all in protecting alex's body
from the downhill crash but even
post-modern vehicle engineering had its
limits his breath came in slow ragged
gasps difficult at first but gradually
steady not an improvement in his
condition but rather his body dedicating
the rapidly dwindling resources at its
disposal into keeping vital functions
going as long as possible opening his
eyes alex was surprised to find himself
right side up less surprised to look
down at the shattered mess his limbs and
lower body had become gradually alex's
thoughts clear his sense of self
returning after the bone jarring dropped
down the steep incline and sudden stop
at the end looking to his right he could
see the trunk of the tree that had
stopped his out of control tumble
despite himself alex laugh a weak
gurgling chuckle so it was the cliff and
a tree after all he focused on breathing
letting the waves of pain wash over him
until his brain eventually canceled the
mount by injecting his broken body with
adrenaline and chemicals everything was
quiet and still after the crash and the
rain but to a surprise you could hear
something it was faint at first just a
soft crunch of footsteps on gravel but
the sound grew louder and louder until
at last it came to a stop outside alex's
window with every ounce of effort alex
turned his head towards the sound a
rescuer no impossible nobody was up on
this mountain and nobody could possibly
have reached him here so quickly even if
there had been he supposed he should
have been surprised yet almost from the
moment that his eyes fell on the tall
handsome figure with the casual yet
fashionably cut black suit alex accepted
him for what he was there was no shock
no confusion for the second time tonight
just a calm sense of acceptance the man
probably somewhere in his mid-30s leaned
down to peer in through the window he
said nothing as he casually observed the
extent of alex's injuries satisfied he
laid a hand on alex's shoulder the grip
was firm but not painfully so just
strong enough to communicate i am here
with you things will be all right after
a slight squeeze the figure reached
inside his jacket and produced a pack of
cigarettes packing the tobacco with
swift taps against his palm before
removing two cigarettes and offering one
to alex alex nodded his head a very
small motion that exploded pain across
his shattered body no thank you but that
stuff will kill you alex smiled the man
paused for a moment the ghost of a smile
showing on his face for just a moment
before disappearing returning the
offered cigarette the man took his own
and lit it giving alex a good look at
his face in the light of his cigarette
lighter alex had been right the man
appeared to be somewhere in his mid to
late 30s handsome but not cover model so
just pleasing to the eyes he sported
short hair carefully combed and
perfectly knee completely unaffected by
the slight drizzle that still fell the
more alex looked at him though the less
he could remember about the man's exact
features it wasn't that they changed in
any way but rather that he simply
couldn't hold on to any details for more
than a few seconds i'm dying aren't i
the figure didn't speak nor did it nod
or make any form of verbal or bodily
communication he simply looked and alex
understood alex had never been
particularly religious or spiritual but
in that look he understood that there
was a world beyond and one that he would
very quickly be entering into it was as
if for the first time in his life he was
able to probe that world reality peeling
away just enough to glimpse what was
beyond twisting paths through planes of
shadow and light both shuffling figures
along each and at the very center of it
all a light no a feeling love pulsing
forth like the beating heart of it all
the saints had their angels the wicked
their demons but everyone else in
between the two they had him a guide
someone to watch over them on their
final journey alex coughed it was ending
soon the man took a drag from his
cigarette and removed a handkerchief
from another hidden pocket carefully
dabbing away the blood around alex's
chin then returned to his silent smoking
his vision was beginning to dim around
the edges the noises of the forest
growing more and more distant alex knew
it wouldn't be long now but he had just
one final thing to do as he always knew
they would his thoughts returned to her
here at the end once more he turned his
head towards the passenger side seat
pain exploding across his body with the
motion there just on the far edge of the
seat as his phone having miraculously
survived the crash it was no good though
even if he'd been able to move his
shattered right arm he could never reach
it with his fading strength the smoking
man took one final pull of his cigarette
putting it out on the side of the
vehicle and pocketing the stub then he
reached through the broken driver's side
window alex catching a slight whiff of
cigarette smoke blended with an
unrecognizable but pleasant cologne the
man reached across alex and grabbed the
phone pulling back and looking down at
alex's shattered right hand after a
moment he reached down once more and put
the phone in alex's left hand thank you
the words were barely a whisper he had
to concentrate now willing the pressing
darkness to part just long enough for
one final task the man once more placed
his hand reassuringly on alex's shoulder
and the darkness parted slightly just
enough for what alex needed to do he
worked the phone awkwardly with his left
hand gritting his teeth through the pain
of broken fingers opening a new message
he scrolled down his contacts g h i j
finally k he found her name at last then
began typing out a message i still think
about you every time it rains he moved
his thumb to press send but that's when
alex's body failed him at last the phone
tumbling out of his glass but the man
was there to catch it moving blindly
fast he snatched the falling phone up
and held it carefully to alex's eyes
before pressing send he held the phone
there for alex to see through his fading
vision until at last message sent
confirmed successful delivery the rain
began once more temperamental as it
always is in the pacific northwest fat
heavy raindrops fell on the scene of a
terrible accident the victim seemingly
having died on impact on his lap though
lay his phone and somewhere far away and
far below this dark mountainside a
message notification shirt on a distant
phone
scp-4999 manifests to only one person at
a time and only when they are alone all
subjects to date have been in the final
stages of a terminal illness
suffering from a life-threatening injury
or otherwise on their deathbed it also
appears that all subjects have
personalities and lives that could be
described as nondescript insignificant
or otherwise unremarkable no testing of
scp-4999 has been authorized by the
foundation due to both the difficulty in
predicting where it will appear as well
as the fact that observation seems to
prevent the anomaly from appearing there
are also ethical concerns since many in
the foundation feel that
scp-4999 is providing an important
service to humanity even if it is only
for those on the margins of society and
it is debated whether this should be one
anomalous creature that is allowed to
continue its existence and its work
without interference
what makes someone a hero there is never
just one answer to that question some
will tell you that it's selflessness
putting other people before oneself that
makes someone heroic others believe that
heroism takes someone with a clear sense
of morality the ability to tell right
from wrong with absolute certainty
perhaps a hero should also be a symbol a
paragon of hope and virtue for all of
society to look up to and aspire to be
and then there are those who would argue
that a person can't possibly be a hero
unless they possess one key trait
whether that comes as a result of a
freak accident gamma radiation exposure
or mutated genes being blessed with
extraordinary powers and the will to use
them for good might just be what
elevates a moral selfless and symbolic
hero into something more a super hero it
is rare that the scp foundation
encounters an anomalous creature or
entity that it considers to be harmless
there are of course exceptions but
perhaps even more of a rarity is an scp
that seeks to go out of its way and use
its anomalous abilities to do good so
many of the creatures and entities kept
contained by the foundation have
malicious intent like damage
regenerating reptiles with contempt for
humanity and eldritch beings with
desires to take over this dimension but
then there is
scp-2800 or as he prefers to call
himself cactus man the spiked menace
partially human and part succulent plant
scp-2800 is one of a rare breed of scps
one that aims to help people rather than
killing them enslaving them or wiping
reality as we know it from existence and
as you might be surprised to learn that
this superhero known as cactus man began
life as one daniel mcintyre an average
guy from scotland little is known about
daniel's origin story all superheroes
have one of course but as far as
foundation researchers are aware cactus
man wasn't jettisoned in a pod from his
dying homeworld to the safety of earth
it is also safe to assume he didn't get
pricked by a radioactive cactus or have
his dna infused with a plant during a
genetic experiment he was first
encountered by the scp foundation whilst
they were trying to contain another scp
a reality warping object that had
somehow breached containment what
foundation staff tracking the object
witnessed was cactus man attempting to
assault the escaped scp too little
success following this encounter
foundation personnel convinced cactus
man to allow them to contain him he
complied was designated as scp-2800
and researchers began investigating the
nature of this strange would-be
superhero according to daniel one day
his powers just happened with little
understanding as to how why or what had
caused this transformation when asked
about how he acquired his powers during
an interview with scp foundation
researcher dr love daniel said taviana
stuck i don't know i woke up one day and
boom cactus powers thought i might as
well use them for good right i always
grew up reading a lot of comic books
always loved the x-men as a little kid
so i thought i was one of them
i thought i was the luckiest guy in the
world ending up with superpowers doesn't
every kid wish they could be a superhero
analysis by foundation research staff
revealed that daniel's dna had somehow
merged with the genome of a carnegie
gigantea plant or a saguaro cactus this
plant is usually what most people
picture if they were to imagine a
typical cactus
and is known to be native to the sonoran
desert as well as the mexican state of
sonora
how one became part of daniel mcintyre's
genetic makeup is baffling it seems
highly unlikely that a saguaro cactus
would grow naturally in scotland given
that the country has a far damper and
colder climate than the scorching hot
deserts that saguaros normally thrive in
regardless of exactly how daniel became
fused with a cactus his body shares a
number of the same physical properties
of the plant pointed spikes protrude
from his skin which can grow to just
over an inch in length it seems that
scp-2800 can either remove these spikes
manually with little pain or will
eventually shed them naturally over time
allowing more to regrow in their place
as well as outwardly looking like an
anthropomorphic cactus
scp-2800 also shares various biological
traits with his cacti counterparts
daniel's body no longer functions in the
same way as that of an ordinary human
being in a number of different ways
firstly he is able to perform
photosynthesis deriving the necessary
nutrients he requires from direct
sunlight this negates the need for him
to consume any food and prevents him
from feeling hunger or the fatigue this
can often bring additionally his altered
biology allows cactus men to store more
water than would normally be possible
for the average human and he requires
less of it too
scp-2800 is able to keep himself
hydrated with a third of the required
fluids for an average person daniel can
also adapt to more arid environments
with drier climates and above average
levels of heat having little impact on
his abilities speaking of abilities
scp-2800 is not just a man with the
physical and biological traits of a
saguaro cactus he also has superpowers
that seem
well let's say inspired by a cactus
while perhaps not as flashy as being
faster than a speeding bullet more
powerful than a locomotive or able to
leap tall buildings in a single bound
cactus man does possess his own unique
set of superhuman abilities derived like
his other traits from his parts saguaro
dna
scp-2800 has the power to empathetically
communicate with other plant life unlike
telepathy and the ability to communicate
solely through thoughts empaths like
cactus men are able to influence or
interpret the emotions or moods of
others so similar but a little more
subtle in its effectiveness cactus man
might have superhuman powers alter dna
and a mysterious origin but another part
of a hero's journey is the struggle and
scp-2800
is no exception to this either despite
his desire to do good he harbors a lot
of unrest under that prickly exterior
after extensive psychological
examination by the researchers at the
scp foundation daniel was diagnosed with
two distinct mental disorders the first
of these is dysmithia or chronic
depression with the other being a
condition colloquially known as hero
syndrome hero syndrome as its name
suggests is often characterized by an
unstoppable pathological urge to help
people usually ignoring any risks to
oneself in the pursuit of assisting even
total strangers some with this disorder
will even attempt to manufacture
dangerous scenarios in order to act like
the hero and earn themselves recognition
and praise for reacting heroically to
the danger they secretly caused like for
example committing arsons so they can
save people from a burning building
scp-2800 has never attempted anything
like this so far but cactus man does
express an extreme willingness to help
people and try to intervene in any
situation that he thinks he can assist
with the problem is
scp-2800 is hardly an experienced crime
fighter and this has put him on the
receiving end of his fair share of
injuries during his first outing as
cactus man the spiked menace daniel
encountered a group engaging in the sale
of illicit substances and attempted to
apprehend them while he was able to deal
a cactus spine-filled blow to one of
their faces the group quickly
overpowered cactus men and beat him
until local law enforcement arrived to
save him determined to prove himself a
hero though daniel returned to
patrolling the streets soon after but
met with the same results even weak
petty criminals seemed like they were
too much for cactus man to handle while
his hero syndrome compels scp-2800 to
want to do good and set a good example
it is also directly linked to his other
condition his dysmithia by attempting
and failing to be heroic cactus man
becomes chronically depressed yet still
has the urges brought on by his hero
syndrome to put himself in harm's way
for the sake of others and when he is
unable to provide help daniel falls back
into depression it's a very difficult
cycle in the hopes of counteracting some
of daniel's struggles the scp foundation
have gifted him a pair of potted cacti
these occupy scp-2800 cell with him both
oxygenating his room as well as boosting
his morale although he has remarked that
the cacti don't say much to him beyond
i'm thirsty and i am a cactus daniel has
affectionately named his potted plants
they're now known as cactalad and spiky
girl his sidekicks in the never ending
battle against evil during interviews
with foundation researcher dr love
daniel admitted that he was a victim of
bullying throughout much of his
childhood from a young age he often
found himself in physical altercations
with bullies that singled him out and
picked on him at school cactus man said
that his experiences encouraged him to
give back and that despite having
suffered at the hands of bullies it made
scp-2800 determined to help others in
need in his own words daniel didn't want
what happened to him to happen to
anybody else and it is highly likely
that these experiences from his youth
are at least part of the cause of his
hero syndrome however another incident
may also be linked to scp-2800's
condition despite not often prevailing
against petty criminals there is cctv
surveillance footage of cactus men from
before his containment by the scp
foundation the footage in question was
taken at a subway close to where daniel
patrolled and looked for criminals to
apprehend in the surveillance tape a
woman and her child can be seen waiting
at the subway station near a support
pillar from behind the pillar an
assailant in a mask appeared wielding
what looked to be a knife the woman
cowering and trying to protect her child
was made to open her purse as the
attacker threatened her with his knife
but then cactus man appeared behind the
man he walked up to him and punched him
in his lower back and chest a number of
scp-2800 sharp cacti spines end up
lodged in the man's skin causing him to
drop the knife in pain during the
ensuing scuffle
scp-2800 was able to tie the man up thus
saving the woman and her child the woman
then thanked cactus man shaking his hand
and embracing him her child also
expressed gratitude with scp-2800
kneeling down to face them and appearing
to get emotional at receiving
recognition after signing an autograph
for the child cactus man then
disappeared from the scene before police
arrived cacti have the tenacity to grow
in barren desert environments surviving
on very little water it is for that
reason that to some these plants have
come to symbolize strength resilience
and endurance this one encounter
captured in this surveillance footage
may well have been one of the few times
cactus man ever succeeded at being
heroic but perhaps it is all he needed
to encourage him to keep trying to seek
out wrongdoings time and time again even
if it led to him being injured maybe
knowing that just once he had succeeded
in saving a woman and her child was
enough to convince him that he would one
day be able to do so again and maybe
that is what makes someone a true hero
the power to endure
a tangled mass of yarn and ribbon sounds
more like what you'd find in the back
room of a craft store or a forgotten
closet than a mysterious creature worthy
of investigation and yet that's exactly
what
scp-066 appeared to be or at least it
did at first glance but the scp
foundation doesn't contain and study
just anything and there was and still is
something incredibly strange just below
the surface of scp-066
also known as eric's toy at first eric's
toy seemed to be completely harmless and
even helpful a knot of string that
produced strange but harmless items and
effects but the foundation soon
discovered a dark side to scp-066
while it may be referred to as a toy
this is no mere play thing
scp-066 weighs only about one kilogram
and appears to be a braided bunch of
yarn and ribbon though there is no
apparent musical capability within the
strands of yarn and ribbon themselves
music can be produced by moving
individual strands one at a time when it
was first being studied this scp was
composed of multi-colored strings and
ribbons but it has since undergone a
transformation and now presents an
appearance somewhat different from its
initial description the strands of yarn
and ribbon can be used to play the notes
of a diatonic scale c d e f g a b though
the research has not been able to
determine just how
scp-066 produces music or any sound at
all
scp-066 was thought to be completely
benign at first and was classified as
safe but following an incident known as
incident 066-2
its classification was adjusted to a
sub-category of euclid euclid impetus
euclid is a classification given to scps
that are more difficult to contain than
those classified as safe impetus in
latin means attack and specifies that
scp-066
is not only euclid class but on the more
aggressive side while 066 is not always
aggressive towards humans the events of
incident 066-2 prove that it is highly
unpredictable and should not be provoked
like many scps it proved that
underestimating its capabilities can be
a dangerous mistake before the incident
scp-066 displayed only charming if
unusual behavior various researchers
spent their time playing random
assortment of notes using its strings
curious about what would happen and
determined to record anything this
unusual ball of string had to offer they
did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hostility and went about
their work with a lighthearted carefree
spirit after playing an improvised six
note melody with the strands a
researcher was thrilled to find that
scp-066 was capable of shape-shifting
its appearance changed to resemble a
small calico kitten for 17 minutes the
kitten was incredibly friendly rubbing
its head against the researcher's glove
hand and purring loudly ironically
enough the kitten also spent time
playing with a piece of string after the
17 minutes were up the kitten
transformed back into
scp-066's original form a few days later
another researcher played a different
melody on the strands and was surprised
to find that when they stopped the music
continued on its own the sound of an
acoustic guitar kicked in accompanied by
vocals with no visible source for either
sound the scp then played a four-minute
song with lyrics warning against the use
of sharp objects without the supervision
of a parent especially scissors after
the song ended the scp was silent for
the rest of the day the following week a
research assistant used the strands of
scp-066 to play the opening notes of
happy birthday and a chocolate cupcake
with a lit birthday candle appeared from
within the braided strings
against the warning of his peers the
assistant ate the cupcake in response
the scp played the rest of happy
birthday and the assistant suffered no
adverse effects from the cupcake
all this fun was brought to a swift end
when one scientist suggested that a
portion of
scp-066's yarn body be cut off and
removed so that the specimen could be
tested
on april 18 2008 the event that would
become known as incident 066-2 took
place
a young man known only as d066-4437
or d was assigned to the task
naturally he was a member of the highly
disposable d-class personnel but dee was
grateful for the opportunity as most
experiments of a similar nature involved
quite a bit more obvious risk
it was a simple enough job
take a pair of scissors snip off some
yarn and bring it back to the lab for
further study
it was hardly on the level of
supervising 173
or being 682's latest chew toy
he entered the containment room where
scp-066 was lying dormant and still and
approached it with scissors he grabbed a
small handful of string and started to
cut as soon as the scissors began to cut
through the fabric the scp rolled out of
his grasp it came to a stop one meter
away
where it started to make a high-pitched
squeaking sound resembling the cry of a
frightened rabbit unsure what to do and
unprepared for this scenario d
approached the entity again he snagged
another fistful of yarn and cut only for
066 to curl into a ball and roll away
from him again even faster this time
once it was safely on the other side of
the room and away from the scissors it
stopped moving only this time it didn't
squeak instead for the very first time
since its containment it spoke in a deep
uncannily human voice and asked
are you eric after recovering from his
initial shock at hearing a voice come
out of a massive string he responded no
i'm not this answer said something off
in scp-066
and its form began to shift and change
the string wriggled around on the floor
unbraiding and wrapping around itself
into a mound the colors previously a
rainbow of shades shifted until every
strand was a blood red much to dee's
horror the transformation was not yet
complete small bumps began to emerge
from the spaces between the strands of
yarn popping out all over the bright red
mass if that wasn't terrifying enough
suddenly all together as one they
blinked open revealing themselves to be
over a dozen small eyes every single eye
was focused at d studying him staring
him down
scp-06 then began to produce loud abrupt
dissonant notes like someone banging on
the keys of a piano d had seen enough he
abandoned his task and fled the
containment room after this failed
attempt to extract a sample
scp-066's behavior and its treatment of
personnel who interacted with it began
to change dramatically before the
incident the scp was largely dormant
only becoming active if a melody was
played using its strands following the
incident and its change of form 066
began to move on its own long strands of
its yarn body would move like tentacles
writhing and wriggling around at high
speed it no longer needed human
interaction in order to produce sound or
to produce any other effects at the
sight of any human regardless of the
human's behavior the scp would begin to
react with sound and effect within six
seconds the first of these effects was
noted by a research assistant who
entered the scp's containment facility a
week after the incident with dee
as she approached 066 to take notes
about its current state and its new
ability to move a bee appeared out of
nowhere it stung the assistant and flew
away before it could be captured weeks
later a team of 11 personnel were
monitoring the scp when it suddenly
burst into a rendition of beethoven's
second symphony it produced this music
at a volume of over 140 decibels
permanently deafening three of the
personnel and causing permanent hearing
damage in the other aid it was theorized
that the scp did this as an act of
retribution for its perceived
mistreatment these personnel refused to
work with scp-066 again when a new team
was assigned to monitor the entity
everything seemed to be going well at
first it was moving around flailing its
tentacles of yarn at nothing in
particular and staring at the personnel
with its many eyes but otherwise was on
its best behavior then suddenly every
light in the room went dark and there
was a complete loss of visibility the
lights were unable to be turned on for
five hours and any attempt at an
alternate light source such as a
flashlight was unsuccessful it was as if
the darkness in the room swallowed any
and all light right up it was similar to
the oppressive darkness within scp-087
or the unlimited black of
scp-3001's shadow dimension the
personnel in the room later reported
hearing the sound of loud labor
breathing just behind their shoulders
though when they searched for a source
of the sound they could find nothing
there had been no recent anomalies
reported or any additional hostile
behavior instead whenever it sees a new
human
scp-066 repeats the name eric again and
again in the same deep voice
who is eric no one at the facility knows
or if they do they have not reported it
to any official channels it is possible
that the scp was once owned by someone
named eric and perhaps given the
circumstances under which
scp-066 first said the name eric
attempted to cut the threads of the
entity while it was in his care
unfortunately there are no official
records of how
scp-066 was discovered or why it was
brought to the foundation in the first
place its origins remain murky and as
mysterious as everything else about it
all that is known is that whoever eric
is
scp-066 is determined to find him once
the scp's class was changed from safe to
euclid its containment procedures had to
be adjusted
while it was previously kept in a simple
room it is now contained in a tungsten
carbide box at its site's high value
item storage facility once a month the
box is inspected for damage to its
interior due to the scp's tendency to
use its appendages to wear down the
walls of the box over time
if there is any damage
scp-066 is to be moved to a new box
using a robotic arm that performs this
transfer in less than three seconds the
foundation has attempted to place
recording devices in the box with the
entity in order to monitor its behavior
when there are no humans present but the
scp destroys every recording device
placed inside of its containment box and
any attempts to record its behavior when
it is not being observed by humans have
been unsuccessful whatever it's doing
when there is no one around it wants to
keep a secret
on the surface
scp-066 is one of the less frightening
finds contained within the walls of the
scp foundation it does not have claws or
teeth or the ability to cause mass
deaths but it has incredible
unpredictable capabilities and seems
very capable of holding a grudge there
is so much that is unknown about it from
its origins to its form to its ability
to manifest matter from nothing and
there is something deeply unsettling
about this scp's unpredictable behavior
and increased hostility towards being
observed we do not know what it is done
and we do not know what it will do next
all we can do is wonder as we ponder the
nature of
scp-066 it does nothing but sit staring
with unblinking eyes waiting for eric to
come back
are you sitting comfortably we know a
good chair is hard to find maybe you're
watching this on your phone while you
lie in bed or maybe you're watching at
your desk sitting in an office chair
maybe you're even watching it while
you're in the bathroom it's fine we're
not here to judge for our money you just
can't beat a nice classic wooden chair
with soft leather upholstery call us
old-fashioned but some things just never
go out of style take a chair like
scp-1609 for example this fine piece of
mahogany was once a chair that simply
couldn't be beat in its quest to bring
its users a little dose of comfort and
refinement in their daily life tell us
have you ever been on your feet all day
just walking and walking and walking and
at a certain point you're just begging
for a nice comfy chair that'll let you
take the weight off your feet for a
little while you would have been
scp-1609's favorite kind of person after
all it was the only chair that literally
sought out weary travelers and even did
you the courtesy of tucking itself in
that's not a metaphor either
scp-1609 could literally teleport to
nearby people who needed to sit down and
didn't have a chair to fulfill that
desire it was nothing but a nice helpful
anomaly that wanted to help people rest
when they needed it most the more
observant members of you have noticed
that we've been using the past tense so
far that's because while
scp-1609 is still an active anomaly it
isn't a chair anymore and this
transformation wasn't something that
scp-1609 planned anticipated or even
wanted the story of 1609's
transformation even strikes to the core
of one of the foundation's oldest and
most bitterly held rivalries with
another group of interest it's the tale
of how a helpful piece of anomalous
furniture became a paranoid killer but
first we need to talk about containment
procedures like a word you see so often
that it starts to lose meaning
containment and specific containment
procedures are concepts so integral to
the very existence of the scp foundation
that it is easy to overlook or forget
about them they're one of the three core
pillars of the foundation's mission
statement secure contain protect because
of the centrality of containment to the
foundation's core principles one of the
most valuable roles on the scp
foundation payroll is that of the
containment specialist a vast team of
experts who work with researchers to
figure out the best way to keep every
anomaly contained based on their unique
abilities and attributes they're
zookeepers archivists guards security
and intelligence experts magicians
practitioners of ritual scientists and
so much more in short they're anything
they need to be in order to adapt to the
ever-evolving containment needs of the
anomalies they keep under lock and key
and containment isn't easy aside from
the rare safe class scps which require
incredibly minimal containment resources
the containment of most scps extracts
some kind of cost whether that be
financial time effort or in some
particularly dark cases human life some
scps like scp-974
and
scp-2845 require the sacrifice of human
children to prevent worse fates
befalling many others other scps like
the infamous
scp-231 require the foundation to do
horrifying things to the scp itself to
prevent it from manifesting some even
more horrifying anomalous traits and a
third but equally inconvenient kind of
scp like scp-682 and scp-076
require huge numbers of heavily armed
guards with powerful weapons to keep
their deadly prisoners locked away often
at a massive risk to their own lives
containment isn't easy but it's
ultimately the very thing that makes the
scp foundation the organization it is if
they were instead on a quest to kill and
destroy every anomaly they could get
their hands on then they'd be the global
occult coalition the un's answer to the
scp foundation that prefers to seek
disable and destroy rather than secure
contain and protect it's the primary
characteristic that differentiates these
two titans of the anomalous world who
regularly come to blows and right at the
heart of that difference is scp-1609
as we mentioned earlier
scp-1609 went through a transformation
that changed everything but the scp
foundation never actually knew about the
anomaly prior to that transformation
taking place it first came to their
attention when it literally manifested
within a containment cell in storage
site-08 making the rare move of
willingly submitting itself to the
foundation containment but what showed
up in that cell certainly wasn't a chair
when 1609 appeared all it looked like
was a pile of trash specifically
splinters wood chippings furniture nails
and scraps of bleached leather and
fabric anything that suddenly
infiltrates a secure foundation
containment site is cause for concern
even a bunch of wood scraps so the site
director sent in an armed guard to
investigate the mysterious pile of
debris
researchers watching over a surveillance
feed were surprised when the guard
suddenly entered a state of heightened
distress he fell to his knees coughing
and spluttering until he expelled a
considerable amount of blood from his
mouth and nose he then collapsed on the
ground next to the pile of debris
dead an investigation following this
incident found that the guard had died
after a sudden influx of jagged metal
and wood had teleported inside of him
tearing his lungs apart from the inside
and causing the guard to die a painful
and horrific death naturally the site
personnel were somewhat concerned by
this development they sent in a d-class
to investigate further but were
surprised to find that the d-class in
question was somehow completely fine the
pile of debris that would soon be
designated
scp-1609 made no attempt to harm the
d-class as it had the guard and finding
out why this was the case came as a side
effect of figuring out exactly what had
happened to
scp-1609 through a rigorous
investigation involving more than one
secret foundation mole they discovered
that scp-1609 had previously been in the
possession of you guessed it the global
occult coalition back then it was just a
helpful chair you once knew and loved
until the goc had the bright idea of
forcing it into a wood chipper in order
to destroy it due to its connection to
someone called the carpenter but all the
gocs attempt actually succeeded in doing
was altering its form and completely
changing its personality to put it in
simple terms
scp-1609 is now a pile of possibly
sentient teleporting wood and metal
chippings that suffers from a nasty case
of ptsd the incident with the wood
chipper traumatized scp-1609
and its anxiety is triggered by anything
that reminds it of the goc or the wood
chipper incident this includes wearing
formal clothing lab coats protective
clothing jumpsuits and particularly body
armor but also includes anyone carrying
weapons appearing outwardly aggressive
using common goc lingo or even
mentioning the goc in
scp-1609's proximity if any of this
happens it's extremely likely that
scp-1609 will resort to its only natural
defense mechanism which is teleporting
its debris into the lungs of anyone it
considers to be a threat
the guard had received this grisly
punishment because his clothes weapon
and overall manner caused
scp-1609 to regard him as a threat and
react accordingly you may think this is
overkill on 1609's part but if you were
just trying to help out the chairless
people of the world then someone fed you
into a wood chipper you'd probably be a
little jumpy too since these early days
the foundation has learned to apply a
more tender touch when it comes to
dealing with
scp-1609 and the brilliant containment
specialists even figured out a way to
keep 1609 happily contained by placing
it in a flower bed inside its
containment chamber where its wood chips
get to serve as mulch for a variety of
flowers and plants all attending
researchers and guards dress in plain
clothes and adopt a loose pleasant
attitude while inside whenever they're
around they make a point of saying how
beautiful the flower bed is so that the
disfigured anomaly that only ever wanted
to be helpful can still feel like it's
doing something nice because of these
containment procedures breaches
involving
scp-1609 have remained in the single
digits it is a perfect example of less
really being more when it comes to
containment the head researcher on the
scp-1609 case dr sievert released an
internal document permanently affixed to
the file like a kind of cautionary
signpost it's a clear expression of
exasperation and rage at the actions of
the global occult coalition reading
scp-1609 represents a perfect example of
the flaws inherent in the operating
procedure of the goc and serves as a
cautionary tale for any members of the
foundation who disagree with our
practices on containing dangerous
objects prior to the coalition getting
their hands on this it was perfectly
harmless a chair which teleports to you
when you need to see it is normal
compared to most of the stuff that we
deal with on a regular basis when they
put it through a wood chipper they got
hurt scared and angry so it lashed out
at them by trying to protect the world
by destroying it they inadvertently made
the situation a whole lot worse
scp-1609 went from being harmless to
deadly in the space of a few minutes
because of the goc and we had to clean
up the mess thankfully
scp-1609 is pretty simple for us to deal
with so long as we don't have to do
anything stupid around it it won't fight
back and it won't try to leave even if
it does it usually comes back and i
think i've worked out why it came to us
because it was afraid of the people who
had heard it that's why it always comes
back it's afraid of the rest of the
world now and it's looking to us for
protection this is why we have special
containment procedures instead of
special destruction procedures if you
break something it's broken forever when
you try to destroy an anomaly you can't
take back your mistakes that's what
scp-1609 has to tell us this is why
we're right and the goc is wrong people
but of course there are two sides to
every story and it's important to
understand the goc's perspective on this
whole mess to them this has never been
scp-1609
it's
kte-0937 velveteen aka the sixth chair
it was labeled as the sixth because for
the goc this chair was merely one part
of a wider investigation it belonged to
a six-piece furniture set created by a
dangerous anomalous person of interest
named the carpenter for a classified
customer the goc was able to intercept
this deal and kill the carpenter and his
customer in the process after that all
that was left was to eliminate the
anomalous objects and five of them were
incinerated without incident however
before they could do the same to the
sixth chair they experienced an
incinerator malfunction rather than just
waiting for the incinerator to be fixed
a member of goc personnel decided to
rush the job and run the chair through a
wood chipper it was at this point that
its pieces first lashed out invading the
lungs of this negligent goc member along
with five others killing them all it was
shortly after that that
scp-1609 manifested in foundation
containment much like dr severt did for
the foundation assistant director
kipling one of the goc's legion of
middle managers affixed a note to the
profile of kte 0937 velveteen that reads
kte-0937 velveteen is an object lesson
in the importance of following proper
operating procedures due to the lack of
vigilance by the agent on the scene the
object's threat level was escalated the
object itself was not successfully
disposed of and it has since fallen into
the hands of a hostile agency a single
failure by a single operative resulted
in the deaths of six remember this next
time you think about cutting corners and
that's a good lesson for everyone
whether you're trying to destroy an
anomalous piece of furniture or keeping
its remains happy so they don't try to
kill you cutting corners is always a
fast track to failure
in june of 1985
mark johnson and his wife of 10 years
sophie were on vacation in myrtle beach
having a great time while they relaxed
on the sand sophie decided to take a
picture of her husband for their
scrapbook so she pulled out the polaroid
super color 645 that she'd bought
specifically for the trip she pressed
the button waiting for the picture to
print pulled it out and shook it what
she expected to see was a shot of mark
lying on his beach towel what she got
was a picture of her husband in the arms
of his secretary they say that a picture
speaks a thousand words but this
particular camera takes pictures that
are worth even more than that when
developed the pictures taken with this
normal looking polaroid camera reveal
the innermost desires of the person
being photographed welcome to the story
of
scp-978 the desire camera the main
reason the foundation keeps
scp-978 under wraps is due to its use as
an easy form of blackmail all anyone
with access to the camera would have to
do is snap a few covert photos and
they'd have instant dirt on the world's
most powerful people to further stop
this camera from falling into the wrong
hands the containment guidelines
strictly forbid the use of the camera
for anything other than simple
documentation and all uses of it must be
thoroughly logged and checked so now
that you know what the camera does it's
time to look at what kinds of strange
and mysterious photos it's taken after
all who doesn't want a chance to gain
insight into the minds of the
foundation's most famous and dangerous
inmates first to serve as a control the
team took a photo of a blue office chair
no change was recorded proving that the
camera didn't work on non-anomalous
inanimate objects some of the earliest
tests of the camera were the photos that
the research team took of each other one
by one the doctors and their assistants
were photographed in neutral poses
smiling as if for a completely normal
photo then they waited while the photos
developed like normal polaroids most of
the research team had minimal changes in
their photos one was shown slouched in
his chair drinking from a flask one was
shown in her civilian clothes getting
ready to go home from work one doctor
was in the exact same pose but with a
different colored tie on the last
assistant photographed however had their
picture come out wildly different than
how they were posed their desire
revealed by the camera was so shocking
that it had to be redacted and the
assistant was placed on temporary
psychiatric leave following this first
successful test the doctor in charge of
the project ordered a second round of
tests to be conducted this time on a
series of d-class personnel a picture of
one d-class who was photographed while
eating in the cafeteria showed up as
scuba diving on vacation with his wife
and child he was allowed to keep the
picture afterwards another had a similar
result he was photographed in a neutral
pose like the members of the research
team had been and when the picture
developed the d-class was seen holding a
smiling baby whom he identified as his
one-year-old daughter after that the
results of the scp-978 test started to
get a little
well
weird a notoriously twisted d-class
known as 7294 was photographed in his
cell and when the polaroid developed he
was in the same cell playing a cello
made out of a dismembered mannequin
d-217-017 was a late-stage victim of
scp-217
a virus that turns organic matter into
metal you would assume that her
innermost desire would be to be cured of
her disease but when she was
photographed in her cell the resulting
polaroid showed her completely made of
metal kneeling and praying at the base
of a black obelisk one d-class who had
been rendered comatose and was on life
support was photographed in their
hospital room their picture showed them
as only a limp deflated skin in their
photo the photograph of another d-class
who had become increasingly listless and
apathetic since their integration into
the d-class program
resulted in a picture that was exactly
the same as they appeared in reality
except the light in their cell was
slightly dimmer intrigued by these
results the research team wanted to see
how the camera would react to
scp-148 a type of metal that blocks the
psychic properties of other scps a
helmet was made from the material and
placed on a d-class who was given an
adult magazine to read while his photo
was taken when the photo was developed
it was extremely blurry upon close
analysis the figure of the d-class
reading the magazine could still be made
out and around him the faint images of
several nude people could be seen the
research team wanted to see if the
results were the same when the camera
was used on animals photos of the lab
mice and rabbits showed them eating or
mating in their respective polaroids a
zebra finch was shown escaping its cage
while a guard dog and its handler were
shown playing fetch in the park when
cockroaches were photographed there was
no difference visible between the
picture and reality but the most
exciting test results came when the
camera was tested on other scps for a
few of the scps tested there was no
visible difference between the picture
and reality this was the case for
scp-173 the sculpture
scp-343 nicknamed god scp-014
an immortal man who is over time being
turned into concrete and
scp-063 the world's best toothbrush when
scp-035 better known as the possessive
mask was photographed in its glass case
the picture showed an unidentified
individual wearing the mask sitting on a
throne and surrounded by three masked
corpses the team took a picture of
scp-043
a haunted copy of the white album that
was being interrogated while on a
turntable in the picture the album was
being returned to its sleeve they then
photographed
scp-049 the plague doctor standing in
his cell in the picture the plague
doctor is hugging an unidentified small
child and surrounded by instances of
scp-049-2
when they took a picture of
scp-050 a mischievous statue of a monkey
reading a book the result was
predictably playful given that scp's
history of pulling pranks the photo that
came out of the camera showed the camera
itself with another picture of itself
coming out of the developing slot
microscopic analysis revealed that this
recursive photography kept going until
the cameras and the pictures of the
other cameras were too small to see
the team next photographed scp-053
the young girl and the photo was taken
as the young girl was drawing with
crayons in her cell in the picture she
was riding through a sunny field on the
back of her friend
scp-682 scp-053
and
scp-682 were even wearing matching bows
dresses and pink nail polish when they
took a picture of
scp-096 the shy guy though the picture
showed
scp-096's cell with nothing in it
scp-085 the living 2d sketch known as
cassie was photographed tinkering with a
drawn car in the developed photo cassie
was engaged in the same activity but
both she and the car were now
three-dimensional the team took a photo
of scp-106
the old man emerging from a wall within
his cell when the photo developed it
showed the old man roaming a wheat field
near an old farmhouse from the porch of
the farmhouse an older woman is greeting
scp-106 with open arms they also took a
photo of scp-168
a sentient calculator sitting on a table
in its containment cell in the picture a
teenage boy is seen doing complex math
homework using the calculator next to
him on the table are thick textbooks
with titles like complicated math
difficult math and math you need your
calculator for the photo of
scp-261 a vending machine that dispenses
snack products from alternate universes
showed the scp in its usual hallway
almost completely buried in coins
scp-507 an otherwise normal man who
unwillingly teleports between dimensions
was photographed while eating in the
cafeteria the developed picture showed
him dressed as a foundation researcher
talking to other researchers when
scp-682 was photographed floating in its
containment tank the resulting picture
showed the scp surrounded by the corpses
of all of the foundation staff and
mauling the person who had taken the
photo a researcher's note accompanying
this photo reads well that was
predictable yes yes it was just for the
fun of it the team also tested the
camera's effects on a few other
foundation personnel they took a photo
of dr bright while he was arguing with
dr clough the picture that came out
showed a tombstone engraved with the
words jack bright resting at last the
team also took a photo of dr clef as he
stormed out in a huff following the
argument given that clap's face cannot
be photographed they were curious as to
what the results would be the picture
showed little difference compared to
reality save for the fact that cleft's
head was replaced by an image of a hand
making a rude gesture upon closer
examination of the photo the team also
realized that there was a young girl in
the background who strangely had cloven
hooves instead of feet a young
scp-166 perhaps the team then took a
photo of dr fisher holding his pet
hamster contrary to expectations the
picture revealed not dr fisher's desires
but the hamsters showing the hamster
sleeping peacefully in its cage with dr
fisher nowhere to be seen as you can see
from these test logs the effects of the
camera are well
inconsistent with some photos showing
very immediate simple whims another
showing the subject's deepest and most
secret desires while the researchers
working with scp-978 seemed like they
had a lot of fun getting to peek into
the minds of all their co-workers and
test subjects there's no telling what
kind of pandemonium could be unleashed
if someone on the outside ever got a
chance to use it thankfully the camera
which has been classified as safe for
obvious reasons is kept securely in
security locker hj12 at site 17 which
means none of us have to worry about our
own pictures taken by the desire camera
leaking out but if someone did get the
camera out and took your picture what do
you think they'd see
scp-682 had escape containment and it
was all hands on deck at the scp
foundation to try and stop the
creature's rampage all unarmed personnel
were running to escape before 682 had a
chance to rip them apart as the security
team bravely fought to incapacitate the
hard-to-destroy reptile long enough to
return him to his acid tank 682 was on
an all-out offensive stomping through
the scp's item gallery and spewing acid
at anyone who came within range people
items and parts of the room alike were
melting and sizzling as 682 attacked it
was an absolute bloodbath and you'd have
to be insane to try and fight back
against it however one being remained
unfazed by the chaos and stood proud in
the face of the omnicidal monster it was
another scp one who had broken free from
its glass display case in the commotion
who does disturb the prime minister
sinister it said in a high tinny voice i
shall rip your eyes from their sockets
and force you to eat them
scp-682 stopped to see who had
threatened him it was almost laughable
that this thing had dared to make such a
violent threat because there was no way
that this little thing would be able to
stand up to the unkillable 682 but its
size didn't stop it from trying to pick
a fight all the same the scp was a tiny
robot made from junk which looked more
like a sculpture made from scrap that
was found on the side of the road than a
functional automaton its head was made
of an upside down voltmeter giving it
the appearance of a smiling face and its
arms were made of wrenches it was
capable of walking around though it
seemed to have difficulty moving as it
was very top-heavy it took a rusty fist
at scp-682 and continued to threaten him
shouting you do not know the fury you
have unleashed robo-lord the destructor
will end you as cp 682 swiped at the
robot annoyed by its continued attempts
to antagonize him the robot toppled over
and struggled to stand again but when it
did it ran for 682's feet it started to
grab at 682's toes hitting them with its
wrench hands as you might expect this
had almost no effect on 682 you do
realize you are weak pathetic
said 682 raising his claw to get a
better look at the annoying little robot
it responded lies in slander the mayor
of mayhem is the most powerful being in
existence before promptly losing its
grip on 682's claw and falling to the
floor now 682 was really getting tired
of this thing he prepared to swipe at it
again this time using his full strength
which would certainly smash the robot to
pieces but luckily for the robot its
pestering had distracted 682 just long
enough for the foundation security to
sneak up on him before 682 had a chance
to smash the robot the foundation fired
on him with a volley of rockets reducing
him to a misshapen lump the security
team collected up 682's remains ready to
put them back into a backup acid tank
but the task was made slightly more
difficult by the fact that the robot was
running around under foot trying in vain
to now attack them instead what was this
strange little robot that thought it
could attack the unkillable lizard 682
meet
scp-1370 appropriately nicknamed the
pesterbot by foundation personnel
pesterbot is a small robot made of junk
that displays sentience and the ability
to move despite having no power source
everything about
scp-1370 defies common sense the
voltmeter that serves as its head
contains no sensors but it seems unable
to see if the voltmeter is covered its
arms and legs are made of wrenches and
its wooden torso contains a speaker
which it communicates through a tinny
monotone voice pesterbot lives in scp
gallery 27 in a glass display case which
is 125 centimeters tall 50 centimeters
wide and 75 centimeters long level 2
personnel and higher are allowed to
remove the robot from containment at
their discretion but penalties will be
incurred for anyone who doesn't return
it to its case due to its impractical
top-heavy design pesterbot falls over
frequently when it walks around this led
the foundation to believe that he was
created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties
rather than being made with the intent
of being sentient pastorbot has
demonstrated at a high capacity for
learning having been taught how to speak
in english french and latin however the
major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has
nothing to do with its robotic
processing power no it's because of its
poor attitude pesterbot's encounter with
scp-682
and the cockiness it expressed in the
moment wasn't an aberration this scp
really believes it's a killing machine
and as a result it will pick a fight
with anyone and anything that moves
this even includes its own reflection
and as a result the glass of its
container must be made as non-reflective
as possible to prevent the robot from
damaging the case or itself in attempts
to fight its mirror self though its most
commonly used nickname in the foundation
is pesterbot
scp-1370 also goes by a variety of
self-given epithets including doombot
2000 robolord the destructor and darth
claw killflex it can be made to add new
names to this list through encouragement
by staff and one time they even managed
to add the name pesterbot as well as the
even more ridiculous patheticon the
garglemost to its lexicon of names as
you may have surmised pesterbot is
classified as safe and is treated by
most scp foundation employees as a
humorous oddity rather than a legitimate
threat many tests have been done on
pesterbot and they've all conclusively
determined that the robot is incapable
of inflicting any damage to its
opponents in fact pesterbot is more a
danger to itself than to anything around
it both because it's incredibly clumsy
and awkward and because it frequently
picks fights with other scps who are far
more powerful than ant one such scenario
that could have gone far worse for
pesterbot than it did was its encounter
with scp-846
also known as robodude one of the many
dr wondertainment products currently
kept in foundation containment robodude
is an ordinary looking toy robot that
upon request can produce up to 350 robo
accessories that function as real
weapons robodude can deploy everything
from a rocket launcher to a flamethrower
to a gun that shoots out an unknown
species of insect that can chew through
wood however robodude seems to not be
sentient and is unable to use these
weapons unless asked to that ultimately
worked out in the favor of pesterbot
during another
scp-682 escape the two robots were
brought into contact as they both have
been broken out of their respective
containment spaces during the brouhaha
robo-dudes searching for a robo-pal to
play with came upon pesterbot who
immediately started spouting its usual
overdramatic threats i am the crush
master doomed to all i survey pesterbot
said gaze upon my might and weep
identify yourself that i might know
whose destruction i shall sow robo-dude
not programmed to know how to respond to
such a statement simply responded by
asking pesterbot if it wanted to play
pesterbot continued to trash-talk
robo-dude until robodude decided the
best way to play with its new pal was to
engage it in its robo dance mode
pesterbot accepted the challenge saying
activate all that you wish but your fate
is sealed the killotron cannot be
defeated i shall render you until dust
with my mad dancing skills the two
robots proceeded to engage in a dance
battle which the awkwardly shaped
pasterbot failed miserably at while
robodude was a competent dancer
pesterbot could only gyrate pathetically
before it fell over and rolled around
the ground hopelessly out of time to the
music coming from robodude speakers the
song ended and robodude declared
robo-dance is complete robo-pow
pesterbot was unable to accept its
failure and replied ha pathetic one you
have been schooled in the art of the
dance by none other than the meccano
basher scourge of a thousand worlds
kneel before me before i end your
worthless existence robo-dude
unimpressed with pesterbot's poor
sportsmanship deployed its hydrogen
cannon which it was programmed to do
whenever it detected a sore loser
fortunately for pesterbot hydrogen
cannon was just the name for robodude's
water pistol while pesterbot will
attempt to fight anything that moves the
truth is this robot will attack
virtually anything it perceives as being
even slightly alive this is perhaps best
illustrated by one of the tests of
pesterbot's abilities that involve
putting a small speaker at the base of a
potted house plant and speaking through
it from another room the plant was
placed across from pesterbot in the
testing chamber and the interaction was
monitored by researchers from outside
researcher davey spoke through the
speaker in the plant pot he asked
pesterbot if he could hear him and it
answered who dares all cells will burn
you will feel the sharp sting of my
wrath identify yourself so that i may
sing damnation upon you as you die the
robot began approaching the plant davies
speaking as the plant identified himself
i am a split leaf philodendron a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy
leaves at this point he had to try very
hard not to laugh at the absurdity of
this test and the robot's reaction he
continued these leaves can grow up to
three feet long pesterbot used its
wrench to try and wrestle with the
leaves but was bested by the mighty
plant and unable to cause any damage
enraged by its failure it said your
mockery spells your dome i have arrived
you will be crushed betwixt my digits
pesterbot then fell over and was unable
to ride itself it struggled and spent
six minutes trying to stand before its
flailing knocked over the plant which
did nothing to help and in fact pinned
the robot to the ground it was at this
point that the researchers who had taken
time to compose themselves after several
laughing fits enter the chamber and
remove pesterbot in order to place it
back in its containment case despite how
non-threatening pesterbot is there is
actually one situation in the
foundation's history where it actually
posed a somewhat serious threat when
mobile task forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at site
13 also known as
scp-1730 they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of
creatures kept in foundation containment
one of these creatures was pesterbot who
in that universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of machinery it
threw other pieces of metal scrap at the
task force as they tried to leave the
site shouting in a much deeper and more
intimidating voice i am reborn to
breathe devastation upon this fetid
earth pitiful humans you will feel the
dark sting of my never-ending torment
members of the task force could see the
original pesterbot body on top of the
larger metal construct waving its arms
madly the task force opened fire to
little effect pesterbot tossed another
piece of scrap at them just narrowly
missing one task force member threw a
frag grenade at the robot which it
caught blowing up its hand another one
was able to jump into the air and reach
the tiny robot atop the larger body
knocking it against the wall and
shattering it even in the reality where
pesterbot was able to build itself a
larger body it still ultimately wasn't
able to put up that much of a fight poor
pesterbot doomed to be a failure in this
and apparently every other reality
that's the story of scp-1370
also known as pesterbot one of the most
hilariously harmless anomalous entities
that the foundation currently has in
containment perhaps one day he'll
achieve his goal of conquering the
universe he just has to figure out how
to conquer his toy box first
it was the year 2000 and seven-year-old
zenyat chao was like a lot of children
her age bright but ignored she had a
youthful enthusiasm for knowledge and
learning and with the right
encouragement it was obvious she'd go on
to do great things but her parents were
both working two jobs apiece to make
ends meet so outside of school hours
little zenya spent a lot of her time
alone she learned to cook and clean for
herself since it would often be way past
her bedtime when her parents finally got
home from work they communicated largely
through sticky notes left for her on the
fridge before they left for work in the
morning it would be easy for someone
like zenya to fall through the cracks
her potential wasted and get forced into
the same endless rat race as her parents
and that probably would have happened if
her brush with
scp-5094 hadn't changed the course of
her life forever like a lot of parents
who couldn't spend as much time with
their children as they'd like mr and mrs
chao gave zenya occasional gifts as a
way to try and make up for their absence
mostly they gave zenya new books to add
to her growing collection but their
two-bedroom apartment only had so much
space for books a year ago the family
had bought a new desktop computer to
share these days this would be the
answer to a lonely bookworm's prayers
but the internet was still in its
infancy back then everything changed
when her parents bought her a copy of
the miss jay's whiz kids schoolhouse
cd-rom miss jay's whiz kid schoolhouse
was never a popular program produced by
shoot the moon software in 1999 the game
sold poorly on the cd-rom market for
five years until the company filed for
bankruptcy in 2004 but that didn't
matter to zenya as far as she was
concerned receiving a copy of miss jay's
wizkid school house was nothing short of
a miracle and she was far more right
than she knew she didn't have just any
piece of primitive educational software
on her hands xenya chao was playing with
magic after the software loaded a
cheerful figure appeared on zenya's
monitor this was miss j a stylized 2d
teacher in a low res but colorful 3d
classroom what can you learn from miss j
well pretty much anything and zegna as a
lonely kid without many friends had all
the time in the world she spent days on
end learning from miss j and soon zenya
went from a bright child to a bona fide
child genius her largely absent parents
barely even noticed when their child
started demonstrating an advanced
knowledge of mechanical engineering and
a new found fluency in swahili and not
only did miss jay now known to zenya as
miss joyce teaches students with
supernatural effectiveness she also
seemed almost like she was alive she was
a warm calm encouraging figure who took
a genuine personal enthusiasm in the
education and happiness of her students
more than many real teachers even but
sadly not all good things last forever
when zenya turned 12 her family bought a
new computer and the old miss jay's whiz
kid schoolhouse cd-rom was no longer
compatible with the new operating system
the disc gathered dust in the closet
while zenya passed through high school
and then got into a prestigious college
she received her phd several years
earlier than expected and showed such
promise in her scientific field that a
certain organization took notice you
guessed it the scp foundation the
foundation is only interested in adding
the best and brightest to their ranks
and thanks to the tutoring from miss j
zenya chau certainly fit the bill she
was assigned to the role of junior
researcher and little did she know she
was about to run into an old friend in
her new line of work the foundation
first discovered evidence of miss j's
anomalous qualities while researching a
series of strange forum posts in 2012
on a thread discussing abandonware which
is software for which official support
is no longer available there were
multiple reports of a so-called living
character in an old cd-rom many of them
had owned as children seeing as the
technology to use the cd-rom was
obsolete shoot the moons had reportedly
extremely low sales for the title and
nobody on the forum had kept their copy
the foundation classified this apparent
anomaly as neutralized no problem that
was until then junior researcher zenya
chao was briefed on this particular scp
10 years later she remembered exactly
what the forum posters were talking
about and what's more she still had her
old copy at home the senior foundation
researchers were astounded an
opportunity to study this forgotten
anomaly had just fallen into their laps
and it was all thanks to their brilliant
new junior researcher zenya superiors
ordered her to bring in her copy of the
miss jay's whiz kids schoolhouse cd-rom
and then real testing began and after
rigorous examination of the software it
appears by all accounts that miss jay
really is the world's greatest teacher
in spite of the fact she's a collection
of pixels on a basic cd-rom program from
the tail end of the 90s what miss jay
seemed to specialize in was intensive
courses she had the ability to make
students certifiable experts in almost
any subject through courses that can
last upwards of 30 hours and spread out
over just a few days but this isn't as
students become so enraptured and
learning that they forget accounting for
their most basic needs and experience a
decline in process story miss jay's
lesson plans account for regular
bathroom meal and even recreation breaks
for students her talents easily account
for zhenya chao's remarkable academic
success the same success that got her
picked up by the scp foundation
naturally if they had a technology on
their hands that could reliably create
experts and geniuses with seemingly no
negative consequences the foundation
knew that miss j and what she had to
teach could be immensely valuable in
their mission to effectively secure
contain and protect other anomalies but
we're not talking about the chaos
insurgency here the foundation would
never start to use an anomaly for their
own benefit without proper testing so
that's exactly what they did their
experiments on
scp-1594 began at site 15 and after
ascertaining that miss jay posed no real
threat to her students they recruited a
local elementary school to provide human
test subjects closer to miss jay's
intended demographic the foundation
found that there were a few constraints
between every lesson given by miss j to
one of her students before teaching the
really mind-blowingly complex stuff she
would always begin with a basic primer
on letters colors and numbers to make
sure she and her students were all on
the same page another constant was that
all her students would refer to her as
some variation of miss jay with examples
including the names miss julie miss
jenny and miss joy one experiment was
performed on amy myers a little girl
from the third grade her academic
records showed she was a bright and
eager student but she was described by
her teachers as being especially shy amy
referred to miss jay as miss janey and
asked to be given a lesson on her
favorite animal cats of course miss j
gladly obliged and gave amy a 15-hour
lesson split over the course of two days
which the foundation closely observed by
the time the lesson was completed the
results were truly astonishing amy
demonstrated knowledge of feline
behavior diet and physiology on the
level of professional animal behavioral
scientists she became upset when the
session ended and the program was
switched off having become attached to
miss j no further anomalous effects were
reported the next subject was a student
from the second grade named devon
williams devon had a poor academic
record and behavioral issues stemming
from several learning disabilities in
the past teachers had reported devon
having real difficulty engaging with
their lessons and the foundation wanted
to see if miss jay's supernatural
teaching abilities fared any better
devon chose to be educated on the
subject of trains and was given a
15-hour course on the subject's spread
over two days devon had no difficulty
engaging with these lessons and after
their conclusion he displayed a level of
knowledge on railway engineering
comparable to a graduate level education
on the subject devon was so engaged in
his lessons that he had to be physically
removed from the room once the course
had completed because he'd become so
attached to his new teacher the
foundation was feeling extremely
optimistic about the prospect of using
miss j to train potential recruits
seeming as she seemed to be able to
teach even the most difficult juvenile
subjects however the foundation needed
to prove that miss j could be just as
effective teaching adults
for the next test they recruited d14417
a 24 year old member of d-class
personnel who described himself as a
poor student and tested poorly on
pre-screening attentiveness and focus
evaluations he was the perfect candidate
for the first adult test of miss j to
the delight of the foundation higher-ups
d-14417 excel miss j made him a
verifiable expert in law and he was able
to pass a mock bar exam with a grade of
3 10 after his course much like the
children he felt intense sadness once
the experiment ended stating that miss
jay was the best teacher he had ever had
he's since been selectively anesthetized
released and is pursuing a degree in
criminal law with his new knowledge
needless to say the foundation was
impressed the last thing they needed to
know was who exactly this miss j truly
was to do this they'd conduct an
interview and thankfully they already
had someone who had a pre-established
rapport with the subject zenya chow when
zenya began the interview miss j
recognized her immediately she was
delighted to see one of her students go
on to find such success in her chosen
field zegna questioned miss j on what
she truly was and miss j responded that
she honestly wasn't sure all she knew
for sure was that she was passionate
about helping lonely children who love
to learn embrace their education that's
really all there was to it and it
appears she was telling the truth
so far the foundation has found nothing
that hints at a nefarious motivation
behind miss jay's actions it would
appear she truly does just want to help
children
zegna touched by the kindness that this
safe class anomaly showed her as a
neglected child and having now seen the
positive impact that she had on children
like her thanked miss j for all she'd
done and left the interview happy that
there was an scp out there who just
wanted to change people's lives for the
better and probably all of us would be a
little better off if there were more
after all this was one of the few scps
who changed a few good people's lives
for the better and all of us can
probably learn something from the
kindness and patience of miss jay
meet trevor hawthorne now known as d4651
on the outside he was an armed robber
who murdered two people during a
convenience store shootout in texas but
now since being condemned to death he's
been picked up for d-class testing by
the scp foundation now also meet junior
researcher dr julia reed an aspiring
foundation scientist with an undiagnosed
heart condition the kind of heart
condition that doesn't mix well with a
high pressure job at the scp foundation
these two woke up on the morning of
december 6th 2011 completely unaware of
the fact that they were only hours away
from causing one of the most devastating
containment breaches site 19 had seen in
years many people died that day but
thankfully for everyone else
scp-131 were there to save the day when
you think of a hero you probably don't
picture a pair of little cyborgs with
one eye and the intelligence of a
household cat but this is the tale of
how two of the most unassuming anomalies
at site 19 managed to save thousands of
people from two of the site's most
dangerous inmates open your eyes and
keep them open if you so much as blink
it's all over for you how long can you
hold it difficult right now imagine
you're having a staring contest with an
entity that can kill you if you dare to
blink for even a fraction of a second or
even worse a creature that could
potentially kill hundreds or even
thousands of people if your attention
drifts from it for any amount of time
try keeping your eyes open with that
kind of crushing pressure we're talking
about two of the most deadly euclid and
ketter class anomalies out there
scp-173 the killer sculpture a violent
euclid-class entity that is incapable of
moving while being looked at if ever
it's unobserved it'll snap the neck of
anyone nearby
scp-689 known as hunter in the dark is
an equally dangerous and even more
attention-demanding statue these two
entities are beyond dangerous even
scp-682 is terrified of the killer
sculpture and researchers have been
considering the use of 689 to
potentially eliminate the hard to
destroy reptile for quite some time
their greatest concern though is whether
the 30 centimeter tall statue would
cause too much collateral damage to
foundation personnel in the process
trevor hawthorne was part of the
three-man d-class detail meant to clean
out
scp-173's containment chamber at regular
intervals while on cleaning duty two
d-classes can keep staring at the
sculpture while the other tidies up the
cell alternating turns to blink but that
morning trevor had woken up in his
containment cell with a killer migraine
and soon that migraine would be killing
far more than just him
the containment procedures in 689 cell
were also a three-person job 689 is a
small green soapstone statue of a
skeletal being sitting on a throne
believed to be some form of underworld
death deity discovered by german
archaeologists in india this is a work
of religious art that demands your
attention or you and anyone else who's
ever seen this ketter class nightmare
will suffer a horrifying fate anyone
who's ever seen the statue is infected
by its anomalous effects it must be
observed constantly or someone who's
seen it in the past will suddenly drop
dead of a severe health issue like a
stroke or multiple rupturing organs
like the god of death the statue
represents it appears on top of the dead
body of whoever it just killed if not
continually paid attention to it'll keep
hopping from person to person until it's
killed everyone who's ever looked at it
its teleporting abilities and the fact
that it poses a threat to so many make
this a truly formidable foe it's kept in
a constantly lit cell and is observed by
two members of d-class personnel at all
times but a crucial third party in the
containment of
scp-689 is a member of personnel at
level 2 or above they remain in a
control room wearing a special visor to
prevent them from ever seeing 689 and
becoming infected themselves if the
containment fails it's their job to
throw the kill switch on the d-class
observers to prevent them from becoming
vectors for infection today this job
fell on dr julia reed she was linked to
the two observers via an audio feed
allowing her to remain in constant
contact with them and she had her finger
on the activation key for a pair of
explosive collars that were around the
d-class's necks little did they know dr
reed's heart was its own time bomb now
you know what we're up against a snap
happy sculpture and a teleporting death
statue with a hit list containing
everyone who's ever glanced at it what
can scp-131 bring to the table the two
small cycloptic anomalies have only one
remarkable ability they never blink that
and a soft spot for humans these safe
class scps pose no threat to their
handlers and can even form attachments
to researchers and other staff who show
affection towards them of course forming
these bonds is discouraged by site 19's
director because it can be distracting
but that doesn't mean it doesn't happen
the two ipods known as scp-131a
and
scp-131b are identical in appearance
except for their colors a is a burnt
orange and b is a mustard yellow the two
of them appear to communicate with one
another via high-pitched squeaking
noises and also seem to have an innate
ability to detect danger occurring in
the vicinity as well as danger occurring
near individuals they've bonded with
because of their inability to cause harm
and their generally affectionate
demeanor the ipods are allowed to roam
around site-19 provided they keep out of
the way of researchers and stay out of
restricted areas they seem to pretty
much stick to the rules though check-ins
on a b are required every hour just to
be safe as the ipods were moving freely
around the facility trevor and another
d-class maintained a visual on the
sculpture in its containment chamber
while a third man swept up the mixture
of blood and excrement staining the
concrete floors things were going fine
until trevor's migraine got the better
of him a sudden flash of intense pain
shot through his head and in a moment of
weakness he made a terrible mistake with
an audible groan of pain trevor closed
his eyes and forced his fingers to his
temples the groan had taken his fellow
observer off guard and the man's eyes
flitted over to him for a fraction of a
second but a fraction of a second is all
the sculpture needs in an instant trevor
and his fellow watcher had their necks
snapped and the third d-class was
murdered before he even had a chance to
turn around containment protocol
dictates that the door is to be sealed
behind the cleaning crew while they're
working with 173 but this time perhaps
due to complacency the guards had
neglected to reinforce the door they got
their heads twisted 180 degrees for
their trouble
scp-173 was loose mobile task forces
were dispatched to aid in the
re-containment effort as 173 began
wrecking havoc around the facility but
things were about to get even worse it
seemed like business as usual over at
the containment cell of scp-689
two d-classes observed while dr reed
dictated to them over an earpiece from
her control center however what dr reed
thought were just minor chest pains were
actually the onset of heart failure when
the two d-classes heard their supervisor
experiencing a fatal heart attack on the
other end of the line they began to
panic this meant their attention wasn't
entirely on scp-689
and they were further distracted by the
chaos
scp-173 was causing elsewhere in the
facility murdering researchers guards
and maintenance workers alike which led
to power outages the lights in 689's
containment cell shut down guards were
dispatched to execute the observers as
is protocol for 689 containment breaches
but the fact that resources were already
stretched thin by the 173 breach caused
a fatal error in judgment from a guard
posted nearby in a panic he opened the
door to find one d-class dead with the
statue perched on his body and the other
one running straight for him in blind
fear
the two collided and tumbled out into
the hall both were now infected by 689's
anomalous attention and both were now
doomed moments later the two of them
were dead the statue perched on their
bodies accidentally catching the eye of
several researchers and guards running
to deal with the 173 situation for these
two deadly anomalies it was becoming an
all-you-can-kill buffet the staff of
site 19 were now dealing with one
anomaly that needed to be looked at
constantly and another that if you even
glance at it you are effectively
infected with a fatal disease the ipods
sensing an imminent danger nearby
immediately sprung into action it would
be up to these cute harmless anomalies
to save the terrified staff during this
chaotic double containment breach in a
nearby hallway a fleeing foundation
researcher heard the crunches of her
colleague's necks breaking behind her
173 was getting closer this thing
couldn't be outrun she turned and saw
the statue standing there just 10 feet
away from her a dead researcher laying
on the ground in front of it she was
locked in a deadly staring contest with
the sculpture how long she could survive
was now dependent on how long she could
keep her eyes open and it was getting
harder by the second she could feel her
eyes drying they burned under the
ceiling lights 173 just waited this
wasn't a contest she could win in a
final moment of terror the researcher
was forced to finally close her eyes and
she waited for the crunch but it never
came instead she heard familiar
high-pitched squeaking noises she opened
her eyes crying tears of relief
as she saw
scp-131a sitting behind 173 watching it
with its constant unblinking gaze the
killer sculpture was paralyzed by a
cheerful little safe class anomaly
across the facility a similar situation
had unfolded with scp-689
the statue of death had claimed many
lives but scp-131b
had swooped in and frozen the statue in
place with its never-ending gaze soon
after a mobile task force with vision
blocking visors used advanced
echolocation technology to collect
scp-689 and return it to its containment
cell everyone who'd seen the anomaly was
as standard protocol dictates gathered
up for later termination meanwhile a
mobile task force returned the paralyze
173 back to its containment cell with a
forklift no containment breach is ever a
picnic containment breaches with
multiple dangerous anomalies are even
less so but the heroic role that scp-131
played in bringing things back under
control was indispensable after all it's
not just raw power that counts when it
comes to anomalies the only anomalous
power 131 needed to save the entire site
was its ability to keep looking when
nobody else could they're so effective
in this role that they've been seriously
considered for permanent roles as
wardens for scps like 173 and 689 and in
our opinion they're more than qualified
does life imitate art or does art
imitate life it's a question that has
been asked throughout human history this
philosophical debate is about the ways
art either reflects the world around us
or influences it but in the case of
scp-085
the idea of art imitating life takes on
a far more literal meaning this entity
was created during an experiment
involving two separate scps the first of
these was scp-067
which is a fountain pen that when held
by a user will take full control of the
person's hand and arm
scp-067 then either writes about or
draws something linked to the user
holding it the second of these scps was
scp-914
better known as the clockworks this
massive piece of anomalous machinery
will have various effects depending on
what or who is placed inside of it and
which of its several settings is chosen
on the selection panel after test
subject 1101f was given the anomalous
fountain pen the result on the page was
a simple female figure around 6 inches
tall and 1.5 inches wide she was drawn
wearing a summer dress with her long
hair tied back in a ponytail and a
single word was written underneath her
cassandra as part of the experiment the
drawing was placed inside of scp-914
and the fine setting selected this is
the setting that is known to improve the
object placed inside of it in some way
for example a hunk of steel placed
inside will be transformed into a pile
of steel carpet tacks a refined version
of the steel when the drawing was placed
inside something truly amazing happened
cassandra came to life or as she now
prefers to be called cassie
scp-085 sometimes known as hand-drawn
cassie is a completely sentient being
she is fully able to communicate however
it all has to be done non-verbally her
voice cannot be heard by anyone beyond
the page where she was drawn but she is
able to utilize sign language or create
writings on the page in order to
communicate with foundation researchers
scp-085 has been shown to also be
capable of understanding text that is
written on the same paper she exists on
she is fully animated aware of her own
existence and the limitations of being
two-dimensional in nature according to
profiling conducted by the scp
foundation she has her own distinct
personality cassie is good-natured and
agreeable displaying a natural drive and
motivation but also seems to feel the
burden of loneliness living in solitude
on the page it should be noted that any
and all attempts to recreate the same
experiment that formed scp-085 had
failed to create the same or similar
results tragically cassie might be the
only one of her kind in existence a
creation of pure luck with no chance of
making another no wonder she feels so
lonely while cassie's limited to her
two-dimensional form and has so far been
unable to enter our three-dimensional
world she has demonstrated several
different abilities on the page firstly
she is not solely confined to the same
paper she was drawn on
scp-085 is able to transfer herself from
sheet to sheet if another page is placed
flush with hers she will be able to
simply step across onto this new page
however there is a limit to what kind of
page cassie is able to transfer herself
onto she could easily take a stroll
through the pages of today's newspaper
but can't just wander onto someone's
family photos or anything made of
cardboard glass or parchment for that
matter
scp-085 can only exist on paper or
canvas and only when they are directly
connected to her original page according
to foundation testing this is not
exclusive to blank pieces of paper
either if cassie ever transfers herself
onto a page bearing a repeated pattern
like a piece of wallpaper then she will
appear to be in the foreground while
everything else on the paper appears to
be behind her
scp-085 will perceive each page she
enters as a completely new place from
her point of view pattern pages seem to
be like endless space additionally
cassie can also travel to other pieces
of artwork and adopt the same art style
of each new environment she appears in
for example transferring herself onto
the pages of a comic book will cause
cassie to be rendered in an artistic
manner matching that of her surroundings
the same occurs if she travels to an oil
painting watercolor or charcoal sketch
interestingly when appearing in comic
book form cassie's thoughts and speech
are visible through thought bubbles that
are commonly used to display text within
the comic medium her size and the angle
she is viewed from also changes to match
the different panels of the comic page
she is on at one point scp-085 was
introduced by foundation personnel to a
print copy of ascending and descending
by the famous dutch artist m.c escher
this painting is of a large building
with its roof consisting of a looped
never-ending staircase when she
transferred onto the print of escher's
painting
scp-085 curiously explored her new
environment and was able to ascend and
descend the staircase the researcher
gave cassie the name of the piece and
asked for her thoughts on it she
remarked it's pretty i guess would make
a neat exercise track when the
researcher asked if she noticed anything
inconsistent about the staircase cassie
replied no as far as i can tell it just
loops around down up all the time why
don't more staircases do that it's
pretty neat following this cassie
directly requested more impossible
objects or optical illusions to be drawn
onto her page and made part of her
environment unfortunately her request is
still pending review from the o5 council
being able to step from page to page
transferring herself onto canvas or
sheets of paper is but one of
scp-085's unique abilities she can also
interact with other drawn objects on the
same page she is on if someone draws an
item of clothing on her page or a
vehicle even food or drink then cassie
would be able to wear use or consume
those objects drawn for her behave as if
they were real but only when cassie is
directly interacting with them the rest
of the time they remain still just as
they were drawn once scp-085 touches
them these items will animate this same
rule even applies to anything drawn to
depict something in motion for example
trees being blown in the wind or the
waves of an ocean these will also stay
perfectly still when drawn and only move
when acted upon by scp-085
however much like her ability to
transfer from page to page cassie's
power over other two-dimensional
drawings has limits drawing anything
that would normally be an inanimate
object within the real world will
provide scp-085 something that she can
directly interact with but this doesn't
appear to be the case for living beings
like another person or an animal that
would have its own autonomy and freedom
of movement in our three-dimensional
reality animals and people drawn for
cassie to interact with will remain as
static unmoving drawings and will not
become animated like she is even if
drawn using
scp-067 she cannot impart any of her own
sentience or free will onto these
drawings and they remain still even when
she touches them you might think that
drawings of other people whether they
are animated or not might help alleviate
cassie's solitude but if anything it
just reminds her how alone she is
scp foundation researchers have noted
that scp-085 is very friendly towards
them and any subjects brought in to
conduct experiments with her visits from
the three-dimensional world outside the
page she inhabits seems to offer some
relief to cassie's loneliness through
much of her behavior she has shown a
fascination with our reality and in
particular she has an interest in cars
expressing that she wishes she had an
ability to work on them this desire
appears to be completely genuine too as
shown when her photo was taken with
scp-978
the camera that reveals its subject's
inner desires and in cassie's case
showed her in a fully realized 3d
version of herself working on a car
scp-085 curiosity about the world beyond
the page is most likely due to how
different it is from her everyday
two-dimensional existence but on at
least one occasion cassie's curiosity
got the better of her and
unintentionally led to a containment
breach from the moment she was first
drawn to life and even after her initial
testing with researchers
scp-085 seemed unaware that she was a
two-dimensional being in a
three-dimensional world foundation
security protocols regarding scp-085
meant that no one on the research team
assigned to cassie was permitted to tell
her the truth about her 2d nature the
truth about her existence was kept from
her with the best of intentions as
research staff did not want to cause
scp-085 any undue distress or trigger a
possible psychological snap anything
that cassie raised as an inconsistency
or discrepancy within her world on the
page was explained by researchers to be
the result of her imagination or dreams
and research personnel attempted to
convince scp-085 that she was in a
scenario wherein she was the only human
survivor searching for others in a
post-apocalyptic environment however
misguided this decision to conceal the
truth might have been it was at least
done with cassie's best interests at
heart but a lie as they say is harder to
maintain than the truth and keeping
scp-085 in the dark about her true
nature arguably led her to more hardship
that may have been avoided if she had
been allowed to know the truth in the
incident in question a foundation
researcher entered the room where the
drawing pad that cassie resides in was
found and they were carrying a paper
copy of scp-085 special containment
procedures report given that she had
already partaken in tests where she had
transferred herself to other paper and
canvas surfaces cassie assumed that this
file was yet another new environment for
her to explore the researcher allowed
scp-085 to make direct contact with the
report and she was able to transfer over
to the document before the researcher
realized their mistake whether this
occurred accidentally or if this
researcher intended to confront cassie
with the truth about what she was is
unknown nevertheless cassie found
herself on the pages of her own scp
foundation file the record of every test
the research staff had conducted a full
description of how she had first been
drawn by scp-067 and brought to life by
scp-914
all clear as day in black and white
cassie's own true nature was presented
to her immediately the yarns that
foundation researchers had spun about
her surviving an apocalypse began to
unravel was all a lie meant to keep her
in the dark and prevent her from ever
knowing that she was trapped in two
dimensions she returned to her original
page shortly later but the damage was
already done due to her having breached
containment and briefly escaped into her
own file a number of foundation
researchers proposed that scp-085 be
destroyed there was always a risk of
this happening again what would happen
if cassie unwittingly found herself
inside another file with access to more
of the foundation's sensitive
information however the o5 council
decreed that
scp-085 was not to be terminated
allowing cassie to continue to exist
despite the breach ever since she
learned the truth about herself signs of
depression have begun to manifest in her
behavior finding out you are a drawing
trapped in two dimensions with no chance
of ever having someone else for company
would be enough to crush anyone's spirit
but luckily researchers have since
managed to uplift cassie a little and
offer her a welcome distraction from her
unfortunate revelation the optical
illusions like the never-ending
staircase she requested were quickly
drawn into her environment additionally
given the interest she had shown in the
technical drawing of a 1964 ford mustang
convertible
scp-085 had been allowed to assemble a
car of her own by transferring each
individual component of the car from the
blueprint to her page handron cassie had
been gradually building her very own
mustang to keep herself preoccupied from
her life in cartoon motion and in the
end if she can distract herself and find
that tiny bit of happiness isn't that
all that matters in the sense we're all
trapped within our own dimension cassian
or 2d one us in our 3d world filling our
lives with hobbies and entertainment all
in an effort to make sure that we never
tug too hard at the threads of our
reality and find out there just might be
much more out there that we're missing
in the office of scp foundation
researcher yoshihiro takanaka there sits
a small containment capsule filled with
ash
all that's left of a neutralized scp-170
these ashes don't pose any harm they
won't bite burn or assume control of
your mind
but few can hear the sad story of
scp-1762
and not be haunted by its tragic and
mysterious tale
it weighs heavily on the hearts and
minds of all who came into contact with
it during its ultimately brief time in
the foundation's hands
and to think
it all started with a simple little box
with an even simpler message
here be dragons
the box to look at it was really nothing
special a simple cardboard box 32
centimeters by 20 centimeters by 26
centimeters spray painted silver inside
and out its short message scrawled
across the lid and black permanent
marker it appeared on the doorstep of
foundation agent scott thomas who after
determining it wasn't a bomb anthrax or
a deadlier kind of anomaly turned it
into his superiors
that's when it became yoshihiro
takanaka's little pet project
safe class scps are rare treats for any
overworked foundation scientist the box
itself known as scp-1762-1
is certainly important but what's really
interesting is what resides within the
box
if you'd open the box yourself you'd
find that it's empty however when the
box chooses to open itself
it's an entirely different story the box
would sometimes open and emit great
plumes of thick black smoke that would
quickly dissipate around 20 seconds
after this an scp
scp-1762-2 would emerge from the
darkness of the box
1762-2 is the collective names given to
all the beings that exit 1762-1
which are as you may have guessed
dragons
eastern western big small and presenting
in a rainbow of colors these dragons
appear to be living origami sculptures
made from kami paper and have been known
to fly together in large groups and
interact playfully with nearby humans
these little paper dragons would then
swoop around their containment chamber
delighting all who were fortunate enough
to see them for up to three hours
at which point smoke would begin pulling
out of the box once more and the dragons
would return home they'd fly through the
smoke disappearing past the rim of the
box and then the lid would close once
more
the dates on which the box would open
were seemingly random and indeterminable
and didn't appear to work by any kind of
external logic
and what's more the box would sometimes
act as a hub of communication between
this world and another known simply as
fantasy
messages written or carved into various
materials would appear on the lid of the
box mostly after instances of 1762-2
emerging this communication though would
always be one way
attempts to pass messages back through
the box never resulted in success the
foundation staff could only be observers
of the strange world of fantasy never
active participants so why is this
particular scp considered so tragic
we're going to answer that question
right now but just know that what is
learned cannot be unlearned as much as
you might wish you could forget if
you're ready then it's time to learn
about a period of time that lasted just
under a year during which a strange and
sad series of events took place now
known as the jabberwocky event an event
that took hereby dragons from safe
to neutralized
you've seen that
scp-1762 would communicate with
foundation staff via written messages
after each instance of the box opening
the very first message the box gave up
after arriving at the site red you have
found us
thank you it has been so long since we
last saw each other friends
the piece has been upheld the giants and
behemoth have kept their word and have
not caused any trouble since you last
came and gave the order we missed your
company
how has your family been do you know how
to work your room you are welcome to
visit anytime later it gave another
message expressing confusion and concern
on behalf of fantasy's inhabitants
it's strange to see how much your world
has changed it is even stranger to see
how we now appear in this place in
fantasy we are much bigger or maybe
you've grown taller fantasy is still the
same we hope you can visit us like you
used to though our room is as grand as
ever it appears yours has
shrunken we do not understand the rooms
were supposed to be maintained as was
our agreement
please restore the belief
things got worse during the next stage
of the event the box opened and only 20
paper dragons exited this time though
they did not fly and instead walked
slowly across the ground
this was the message that accompanied
this sorry parade of dragons friends we
apologize for our few numbers we have
had to remain in fantasy for quite some
time
the others are growing
impatient
we are trying to keep the peace but
please for all of our happiness
repair the room quickly we know you are
trying
your family is the most imaginative of
us all
naturally foundation scientists were
concerned they weren't sure what exactly
the messages were referring to or how
they could possibly help the inhabitants
of fantasy
of course things only got worse
only 10 dragons appeared the next time
along with a few balls of crumpled up
construction paper that shook violently
before stopping all movement entirely
this message accompanied it the giants
were foolish your room was not ready to
accept them yet
we're sorry friends we hope that we can
still see you but time is growing short
for our happiness and sadly this message
spoke the truth
as the next time the box opened
only five dragons exited
they were carrying the following message
and flew straight back into the box
after depositing it on the ground
tensions are rising fantasy is becoming
darker we the serpents and the hybrids
are furiously trying to hold them back
but the giants and elves wish to strike
and make an entrance they say that your
family has grown stupid and ignorant
we hope this is untrue
it would sadden us all greatly to know
that you have forgotten
it seemed clear that fantasy was
speeding towards some kind of terrible
conflict and it was perhaps too late to
do anything about it the next attempt at
communication came from a single dragon
with a crumpled wounded body
it collapsed to the ground and appeared
to die its body unfolding into a small
piece of paper that brought a single
heartbreaking message
war
goodbye
friends
but two hours after this message was
delivered something happened the lid
opened again only this time the box let
out a huge jet of white hot flame
reaching temperatures of 1700 degrees
celsius the terrified and confused
researchers heard roaring in the sounds
of an intense battle from within the
darkness of the box
many of the observing staff found
themselves overcome with emotion afraid
that they were perhaps witnessing the
death of fantasy play out in front of
them and even hardened foundation
researchers and guards were moved by the
event
at 8 pm that night the box ejected a
huge quality of paper the majority of it
was either torn burnt shredded or
crumpled into balls
and all instances of
1762-2 were announced deceased upon
official examination
it seemed that fantasy's bloody war
truly was taking its toll and even the
forces of the foundation
one of the most powerful and resourceful
groups the world has ever known were
powerless to do anything to help
all they could do was sit wait
and see what the result would be of this
paper-crafted war
the box continued to open and closed
sporadically over the next six weeks as
the war raged on it would often emit
more spouts of deadly fire and vomit out
more piles of ruined paper the
researchers noticed that each time it
released less and less paper even more
disturbing matter resembling muscle and
tissue was ejected from the box with
increased frequency it was clear that
whatever was left of fantasy was in
great peril and the researchers were
desperate to know what was going on
but the box would remain closed and
inactive for the next seven months
when the box did finally become active
once more it wasn't in a way that the
researchers were familiar with the box
opened but not a single dragon exited
not even a crumbled piece of paper came
out
instead researchers found what appeared
to be an ancient and desiccated scroll
of parchment
the words written on it were smudged and
some were stained with blood
it made clear that things had fallen
further into darkness than they had ever
before
the message read are you still out there
friends we miss you dearly
fantasy is no longer safe
our haven
your beautiful creation
is gone the giants are dead the centaurs
are dead the birds have fled
we are going to bury your room
we cannot risk hurting you
this is our goodbye
maybe one day
your family can build another room
this may be a hollow hope
but we will cherish this thought
an hour later the box began to convulse
violently and let out more plumes of
thick black smoke for a moment the
researchers entertained the hope that it
might be the return of the dragons
but no such luck the box began to sag
tear and collapse as though it was on
fire on the inside parts of the box
began to char
and small holes were burned through the
silver paint
perhaps the saddest of all the words
here be dragons were burned from the box
not long after
one more message appeared inside the box
it was a papyrus scroll
depicting a hand-drawn image of a
beautiful mountainous landscape with
huge trees and waterfalls in the
distance a dragon appears to fly away
for the last time
a message written on the back read as
follows
master says that we won't see you again
we are sad so are the remaining others
we once filled each other's heads with
dreams and goals
it is so sad that we cannot share them
any longer
master says we have to go
he says that he will make us a new
fantasy he says you cannot be a part of
it we are sad
we love you we will not forget you
we are scared
will you forget us
when this document was removed streams
of salt water began to leak from the box
feeling its burn scars a few minutes
later the box was returned to its
original state save for one big
difference the text scrawled on the lid
no longer read here be dragons
now
it's said
here were dragons the jabberwocky event
was over the box now neutralized would
sit in yoshihiro takanaka's office for
commemorative purposes
never to release another message
or so we thought in 2015
scp-1762 spoke to us one more time the
box shook and began emitting great
plumes of purple smoke before it fell to
the ground there it ejected two objects
a purple crystal later identified as an
amethyst and a large leather-bound book
the box continued emitting smoke for
another 40 minutes before finally
disintegrating upon further inspection
there was a single message carved into
the amethyst
one last time
and what about the book consider the
greatest fear of the inhabitants of
fantasy that they would one day be
forgotten forgotten and left behind by
us
the book was sent to help prevent that
it's an extensive catalog of the
creatures of fantasy their strange and
wonderful ways in their strange and
wonderful world
even if they're gone they won't be
forgotten and perhaps one day
we'll tell you those stories too
but that's a tale for another day
the young girl stood silently in a room
full of corpses
staring off into the distance
she was in a trance seemingly unaware of
the carnage that had just unfolded
around her
some of the men were shot or stabbed or
beaten
others had no apparent cause of death
whatsoever but the young girl was
unscathed she was wearing a yellow
summer dress and looked like she
couldn't have been more than three years
old she awoke from her trance still
paying no heed to the violence in the
room
and left
this is the story of
scp-053 the young girl
her strange and terrifying life before
containment her thrilling capture
and the part she played in one of the
most dangerous scp foundation cross
tests of all time she had no name the
young girl could never spend enough time
around someone to be given one
it was her terrible courage that she
could never stay in one place for too
long or something truly awful would
happen to everyone around her she'd been
drifting for years
but never grew to look older than a
child her memories were long but
formless divided mostly into 10-minute
increments the young girl kept on moving
it was all she could do
in 1993 when the young girl had already
been alive for a very long time
she found herself in illinois after days
of trekking on the roadside she would
scavenge what little food she needed
from the trash and drink from lakes
rivers or even puddles when she needed
to
deep down the young girl knew that if
she ever grew hungry or thirsty
she would not die
in her travels the young girl had
managed to scrounge together a few
dollars and though she knew her contact
with people had to be limited
there was one thing she wanted that felt
worth the risk
a candy bar
it'd been a long time since she tasted
chocolate and she found the idea of
tasting it again too enticing to resist
when she reached chicago she entered a
small corner store with her handful of
dollars selected the candy bar from the
rack and approached the counter for
reasons even she didn't fully understand
she kept her eyes down as she placed the
money on the counter
you see
scp-053 was always a special child as we
briefly mentioned earlier you might even
say she was cursed whenever she was
around other people for too long
terrible things tended to happen
unspeakable things and as a component of
this strange unexplainable curse or
perhaps as a means of keeping her safe
from it the young girl was doomed to
never understand the nature of her
predicament
it was like there was a mental wall
between her and the horrors her presence
could cause
all she knew was that it was best to
avoid eye contact stay away from large
groups of people at all costs
and never spend any longer than 10
minutes around anyone
ever
that's why as she waited for her
chocolate bar the cash register she kept
her head down and waited to go the
cashier looked upon this strange girl
with apparent concern it'd been a slow
day all in all a few listless patrons
milled around the store window shopping
his brain was practically on autopilot
until he saw this child
she looked filthy in a disheveled dress
and was totally alone
what on earth had happened to this child
the more he looked at her the more he
sensed a creepy vibe exuding from her
something about this girl was wrong
he spoke softly to her introducing
himself as miles
and asking her where her mommy and daddy
were
the young girl hesitated for just a few
seconds too long for his liking before
simply saying that they were at home any
parent who'd let their three-year-old
kid just wander around the south side of
chicago alone was either crazy
neglectful or both
he asked her politely to remain in the
store while he gave the police a quick
call
he'd even let her have the candy bar for
free while she waited
immediately the little girl became
uncomfortable she had already been in
here for a few minutes now and while
miles called the police he expected her
to wait around even longer
again she couldn't even tell you why she
knew waiting around like this would be
so dangerous but she had a nagging
instinctual awareness that she needed to
get out around the store the few patrons
still inside started to get a strange
feeling
like someone was watching them
soon what seemed like mild paranoia was
quickly becoming white hot anger
pure rage they felt almost like they had
to kill someone but not just anyone
someone particular
they had to kill the little girl it
wasn't long until the police arrived two
officers holliday and dewitt entered to
collect the apparently neglected little
girl
it was a story they'd sadly heard all
too often a tragically common occurrence
in the big city when the two of them
approached the young girl she was
looking down at the ground they tried to
speak to her but she was unresponsive
miles looked on concerned but deep down
he felt the same bizarre progression all
the other store goers were feeling
confusion irritability
and finally
violent rage
the corner store was a powder gig
all it needed now was a spark
and that spark came when officer
holliday reached down and took the young
girl by the arm
his bare skin touched hers and it was
all over the cop twitched his mind
washed out in murderous insanity as he
reached for his sidearm
officer dewitt opened his mouth to
protest but he didn't manage to get a
syllable out before holliday turned and
shot him in a fraction of a second the
quiet corner store exploded into a
violent bloodbath as the patrons and
cops slaughtered each other all the
while the young girl just stood there in
a trance
everyone was dead within minutes except
miles and the young girl he shakely rose
to his feet his mind carved out by
madness and reached for officer
holliday's discarded pistol
outside of the store the young girl
appeared walking out as if nothing had
happened
inside miles's body was sprawled over
the counter clutching his chest as if
his heart had just exploded this was the
true nature of the young girl's curse
anyone who meets her eye touches her
skin or spends over 10 minutes around
her is destined to slip into a state of
murderous insanity
they'll go into a kill crazy frenzy and
attack anyone around them
until all that is left is them and the
young girl
at which point they'll try to kill her
too but the mere act of attempting to
kill her is also fatal
killing its victims with a massive heart
attack or a seizure
the second part of the girl's curse is
that she herself can never die
she keeps coming back
unknowingly causing more misery and
death along the way
until of course a certain secret
organization took notice that night the
young girl sat in the cavernous interior
of a local abandoned warehouse quietly
eating her hard-earned candy bar
suddenly she heard a quiet crack in the
distance she tried to move her left arm
but found it was numb she could barely
move it the girl turned her head and saw
a tranquilizer dart sticking out of her
skin instinctively she got up and began
to run
limping as her left leg started to lose
all feeling too suddenly she was
surrounded by footsteps as masked men in
swat uniforms emerged out of the
darkness on all sides
the last thing she remembered before
slipping out of consciousness was a
blindfold being pulled over her eyes and
tiny metal handcuffs clasping over her
wrists
when she woke up she was in the nicest
room she had slept in in years
it was 16 feet by 16 feet with toys
books and games
standing across the room from her was a
stranger in a full hazmat suit connected
to a long steel cable leading out of the
room he spoke calmly and politely a
timer on his wrist counted down from 10
minutes
the stranger explained to the young girl
that they would be taking care of her
now and would provide her with all the
toys and games and treats she wanted
provided she cooperated and submitted
willingly to some tests
compared to living out on the streets
with no food or comfort this seemed like
an excellent compromise
she would live in what seemed like
luxury and every so often she'd be taken
to a testing room with a stranger in an
orange jumpsuit
after a few minutes of waiting the
stranger would inevitably go feral and
attempt to kill her and then always die
in the process the strangers in the
hazmat suits told her that all of these
tests were helping them learn extremely
valuable things about her and that soon
they'd have a very special job for her
it would be a wonderful surprise it was
the spring of 1994 that the young girl
now officially designated scp-053
finally received her special mission
several strangers in full hazmat suits
wielding rifles escorted her out of her
usual bedroom
she asked where she was being taken and
was told she was going to meet a new
friend she was taken to one of the
recreational testing rooms and pushed
inside out in front of her she saw
something terrifying a giant reptilian
creature she retreated from it
instinctually hiding behind a chair in
the containment area the giant reptile
didn't move it just sat there
eventually she plucked up the courage to
go and touch the creature before
retreating again no reaction little by
little the young girl gained confidence
and continued to approach and pat the
creature it exhaled through its huge
nostrils and the young girl literally
jumped for joy in her amusement she
began to play with the docile monster
hugging it even drawing on it with a
crayon the observers were truly baffled
what the young girl didn't know was that
she was playing with scp-682
one of the most hateful and aggressive
anomalies under the foundation's
watchful eye
and yet in her presence the creature was
like an overgrown puppy dog after the
test phase the young girl was removed
from the hard to kill reptile's presence
immediately causing the creature to
become violent and murderous once again
after being separated from her strange
new friend the young girl was seen
crying for several minutes
according to all accounts the young girl
is eager to see her friend again someday
though considering the reptile killed
several guards after their separation
the foundation isn't eager to grant her
that wish
scp-053 was classified as euclid and
continues to be held in containment with
her toys books and games rotated out on
a regular basis
seeing as she shows no sign of aging
this ongoing containment is likely to be
the sad strange fate of the young girl
an anomaly that never wanted to hurt
anyone but an important and cruel
reminder that what we want doesn't
always influence the world in the way we
want over 50 men and women clad in red
robes kneel before an unholy altar they
chant and mutter indecipherable words
words of cruelty and madness of
obsession and sacrilege not long ago
these were regular people computer
technicians teachers plumbers
construction workers accountants
this was before they fell under the
ungodly influence of a new ruler the
center of this makeshift place of
worship was once a normal school
gymnasium but it's now the home of a
huge statue a humanoid being wreathed in
tentacles its head is more like a squid
or cuttlefish than anything resembling
an actual human face
while he's known to the cultists as the
tentacled god the beast they worship is
known to the scp foundation as scp-2662
and he sits in the belly of one of their
expansive containment facilities locked
away from the world but not for long if
his devoted followers have anything to
say about it this is their god all
powerful and unchanging and when it
comes to springing him from containment
no tactic is too vile or underhanded to
get the job done their mortal leader and
high priest a man in a purple robe
calling himself brother marsh
walks among their crouched forms he
whispers instructions for the great day
of liberation that's soon to come
providing everyone plays their part it's
a plan months in the making and one that
if it goes off without a hitch could
free their monstrous god into the world
they would strike at the very heart of
their enemy the scp foundation when they
least expect it and nothing shall stand
in their way how could they lose when
they have a god on their side but why
did all these normal people become
violent zealots for a squid-faced deity
it all began with a dream to those who
experienced these dreams they felt more
like prophecies premonitions of the
glorious horrors to come a red sky
billions dead and billions more enslaved
a dark silhouette on the horizon
their tentacled god holding dominion
over all at first it just seemed like a
strange nightmare the ones who
experienced it woke up shaken and afraid
hoping to shake the images from their
mind but they couldn't
every night the nightmare would return
they'd see the images the red sky the
dead and enslaved the tentacled god
and after a while it would come to them
even when they weren't asleep
eventually happening whenever they
closed their eyes little by little this
scene stopped looking so hideous
and started to look
glorious
they felt his presence in their minds
slowly pushing them towards their
inevitable future they started to
realize that they wanted him to rule
over the universe
and to experience the honor of serving
him many of them abandoned their homes
and families leaving their friends and
loved ones left to worry that they'd
gone insane
in their eyes they were safer than
they'd ever been they finally had
purpose they were working in service of
something far greater than themselves
the influence of the tentacled god drew
them closer to one another
they would meet in secret exchanging
information from the prophecies their
ruler sent to them in their dreams they
worshiped together building altars and
idols to congregate around they
performed dark blood rituals involving
human and animal sacrifice it was when
brother marsh the anointed one arrived
to guide them towards their true mission
that things kicked into high gear
just three months prior brother marsh
had been an office drone working in data
entry for a large insurance company
before the tentacled god invaded his
thoughts with a simple message
free me
and the new world i create shall be your
playground
since then he devoted himself completely
to the cause quitting his job and maxing
out his credit cards to help fund his
new life's purpose infiltrating the scp
foundation and releasing his inhuman
ruler from its imprisonment
that was the single goal he united the
cultists under freedom for the tentacled
god and at long last they had all the
pieces in place to strike they'd finally
gathered the necessary intel to subvert
the will of the most powerful secret
organization on earth
even the strongest institution is made
of people
and people are weak unlike the almighty
tentacled god people could be broken
the people in question were kelly
thompson sydney levitt jordan broche dr
juan gutierrez and jillian larson dr
juan gutierrez was a researcher with
level three clearance on the site where
the tentacled god was being contained
sydney levitt and jordan broche were
both security officers charged with
verifying personnel clearance on site
kelly thompson was a member of site
administration with research
authorization powers and jillian larson
was a research assistant who often
collaborated with dr gutierrez these
five were the key to getting access to
scp-2662
and bringing their plan to fruition
normally personnel dossiers on people
working for the foundation were highly
confidential but the devotees of the
tentacled god had their ways they had a
number of computer experts in their
ranks more than capable of hacking in
and pulling some basic information off
of foundation servers without being
detected for the other information they
needed they turned to some good
old-fashioned torture which is often the
most effective method when you need some
quick results
of course while the colts grip on sanity
may have been a little tenuous they
weren't stupid while gathering their
intel they also made sure to find out
what exactly they were up against
scp-2662 was being held in a humanoid
containment cell and guarded by on-site
task force tau 9 better known as the
belligerent bodyguards these aren't lazy
donut chomping malkops these are a
heavily trained heavily armed fighting
force though the cultists had one thing
that these foundation soldiers didn't
the element of surprise for everything
to go off perfectly brother marsha's
plans would have to be executed within a
single day and they were already on the
clock tau9 had been charged with
tracking down any new
scp-2662 cults and dismantling them and
brother marsh knew that it was only a
matter of time before the foundation
tracked them down and did the same to
them if they wanted any chance of
freeing the tentacled god then they'd
need to strike quickly and with
overwhelming force the
scp-2662 worshipers were able to secure
the addresses of the five key foundation
personnel and station members outside
each of them including one who could
realistically imitate each they waited
for night to fall and broke into each of
their homes as they slept what followed
was a sequence of ruthless and efficient
murders done in the cause of freeing
their god dr gutierrez was shot in the
head while he slept sidney levitt and
jordan broche were both stabbed to death
before either even realized what was
happening thompson who'd gotten up to
use the bathroom went down in the hail
of machine gun fire jillian larson had
seen that mask figures were breaking
into her home and attempted to flee but
was caught and beaten to death by
cultists in her hallway it was a strange
irony that people whose day jobs
entailed working with some of the most
dangerous and nightmarish anomalies
imaginable were murdered in their homes
by nothing more than regular humans
so far brother marsha's plan had gone
perfectly with all five key personnel
murdered within a two minute period next
the selected doppelgangers stole clothes
from their victim's closets and were
handed the correct forge documentation
the next morning each replacement began
their journeys to the site where the
tentacled god was being contained while
the rest of the cult armed themselves in
preparation for their own part in the
plan
nobody at the foundation seemed to
notice anything amiss when the five
arrived on site when you work for the
scp foundation more mental energy is
devoted to following the rules that keep
you alive then two memorizing the faces
of all your co-workers and each one
slipped neatly into position
disappearing into the familiarity of
office life but
infiltrating the site was one thing
getting past the belligerent bodyguards
and into the cell of the tentacled god
would be another thing entirely
that's where the rest of the cult would
come into play heavily armed with
whatever firearms they could get their
hands on the rest of the devotees of the
tentacled god brother marsh included
would attack the containment site head
on
in the ensuing chaos the five cultists
who had already infiltrated the site
could take advantage of the distraction
and break into the containment chamber
it was perfect they launched their
attack from the outside and from within
when brother marsh declared that the
time was right the assault began a
legion of gun wielding cultists seemed
to spring out of nowhere and started
shooting up the warehouse that was a
front for the containment site the site
quickly mobilized guards and task force
members to take on the sudden threat and
just as brother marsh had anticipated
the site director called on the majority
of town nine to help repel the violent
cultists from their perimeter tau9
obeyed leaving three task force members
behind a guard
scp-2662's containment chamber they
expected to be guarding the cell from
rampaging religious zealots seeking an
audience with their god what they didn't
expect was a group of five foundation
employees walking right up to them and
opening fire killing two tau nine
members and taking the third as hostage
while the war was being waged outside
the infiltrators had found the tentacle
god's containment cell in the low-risk
humanoid war
their hostage insisted that using him
wouldn't give them any leverage the rest
of his team would neutralize the whole
group him included if that's what it
took to stop them the infiltrators
explained that using him as leverage was
never their intention he wasn't a
hostage at all
he was a sacrifice
the cultists of the tentacled god
detonated explosives creating a hole in
the wall and finally giving them access
to their deity they climbed through and
gazed upon him in awe there stood
scp-2662
twice as tall as a regular man with 10
huge tentacles emerging from its back in
their months of envisioning this
creature they pictured it sitting on a
throne made of thousands of human bones
ready to dictate its commands to the
obedient liberators what they certainly
didn't expect was to see the tentacled
god hunched over a computer screen
still god's work in mysterious ways so
they stuck to the plan and began
chanting they pulled out a sacrificial
dagger and began sacrificing their
captured tau-9 member it was at this
point that scp-2662
turned and saw what they were doing with
a look of pure horror he rose up from
his computer his headphones getting
caught as he did so he told them to go
away that he didn't want them here and
that the murdering people in his bedroom
like this was inconsiderate and
disgusting the cultists became even more
confused why wasn't their god accepting
their offerings what were they doing
wrong
they tried more chanting and painting
arcane symbols on the floor and blood
but this just seemed to make the
creature angrier he told them in a tone
more fitting for a teenage boy than a
lovecraftian god to just leave him alone
so he could play his video games this
was seriously not cool the cultists were
baffled they told the tentacled god that
they were there to free him he replied
that he didn't need saving
that crazy stalkers like them were why
he turned himself into the foundation in
the first place
before the cultist infiltrators could
get another word in the remaining
members of town nine stormed into the
containment cell and gunned them down
with surgical precision the war outside
was already over brother marsh and the
rest of the cultists were all killed in
the fire fight tao9 didn't look the
least bit surprised upon entering 2662's
cell this was a common occurrence
unfortunately
they had to deal with an attempted cult
invasion every few months because
scp-2662's main anomalous ability is
inspiring violent cults who relentlessly
track down and worship it with arcane
and bloodthirsty rituals the problem is
2662 doesn't do this consciously and
definitely doesn't like the results
that's why he's under the voluntary care
of the scp foundation who keeps him
amused with video games and reading
material while fending off the deranged
cults who try to invade and abduct him
following the termination of the
devotees of the tentacled god just one
of many cults who'd broken into 2662's
containment cell the remaining tau 9
members apologized to the tentacled
creature for the disturbance allowing
him to return to his gaming they assured
him that it'd probably be at least a few
more months before something like this
happened again
scp-2662's cell was repaired and the
foundation returned to its task of
seeking out would-be cult emancipators
because for the scp foundation it's not
always about the anomaly that's being
kept in containment but what's being
kept out
this is impossible the scp site director
wasn't normally a calm or cheerful man
but the researcher had rarely seen him
as angry as he was right now his face
turned a deep beat red as he scanned the
documents on his desk before he asked
how months of valuable research on this
subject had suddenly gone blank the data
was completely gone the researcher
gulped nervously hoping a demotion
wasn't in his future and nodded how
could this be possible this was an
experienced researcher who should have
been taking all the necessary
precautions could the being they were
studying somehow have erased all these
documents himself that's just what the
researcher had been trying to find out
for months with hours and hours spent
trying to learn the extent of its
abilities well where are they the site
director asked i want everything you
have the researcher dropped a printout
of their research on the mysterious
subject's abilities on the director's
desk every relevant line read data lost
the director let out a deep sigh he
wanted to hear everything the researcher
knew well everything he could remember
at least from the beginning the
researchers sat down and began to relay
everything he could about
scp-343 which some of the other
researchers had started to refer to by
the nickname god
scp-343 was first cited in prague just
an unassuming older man wandering the
streets he seemed completely normal to
everyone who passed him by until he
decided he was tired of staying on the
ground an scp agent stationed in the
area noticed the old man disappear from
the streets as if he was blinking out of
existence only to appear on a rooftop
nearby the local scp teams were
marshalled and they had soon tracked
down what seemed to be a very powerful
specimen but scp-343 didn't seem
concerned he reacted calmly when
detained by the foundation and went with
him willingly he was detained in a
standard holding cell for interrogation
and examination but he seemed completely
at ease with his sudden confinement it
would soon become clear that this
ordinary old man was anything but
doctors beckon nidlovu was brought in to
consult on the scp's classification and
that's when the first anomalies began
their assessments matched initially but
when it came time to describe him
physically things took a strange turn
older male seemingly non-descript and
with no unusual physical features
caucasian in appearance dr nadlovu was
confused by what dr beck was describing
in his report this man was clearly black
the two doctors quarreled unable to
square their differing perceptions they
decided to bring in a third impartial
view to settle it their fellow
researcher dr juan she didn't take long
before coming back with her assessment
older male seemingly nondescript and
with no unusual physical features asian
in appearance possibly chinese whatever
scp-343 was he seemed to be perceived by
each staff member as close in appearance
to their own race but that was only the
start of the anomalies surrounding the
old man in the holding cell dr beck
started making regular visits to the
mysterious man and in their first
interview he asked the old man who he
was and how he came by his abilities the
old man had a simple response i created
the universe dr beck stifled the laugh
and decided to indulge the old man's
delusion it was a fascinating claim but
could he prove it without another word
scp-343 got up from his chair laughed
and turned around and walked through the
solid wall in the holding cell and
disappeared dr beck was about to hit the
panic button and marshall the facility's
security to find him when the strange
man reappeared walking through the solid
wall the only thing that was different
he was holding a hamburger which he sat
down and enjoyed the facility quickly
went on lockdown and a full
investigation was done into how scp-340
breached containment but there was no
evidence of any security breach no
failures and containment and no evidence
of any other cells failing
scp-343 hadn't broken through the
security he had just ignored it as if it
wasn't there at all when questioned
about how he had gone on his hamburger
run he simply repeated his belief that
he was god in between bites of his fast
food treat this would be far from the
only time strange things happened around
scp-343
scp containment cells are as secure as
they need to be but even the least
strict containment isn't known for its
decor which is why dr beck was in for a
surprise the next time he paid visit to
scp-343
the bare-bones cell now looked like a
comfortable home decorated in old
english fashions the scientists assumed
that scp-343 had been making many more
trips out of his cell to get accessories
to feel more at home but that didn't
explain all the changes to the cell no
one could explain how he had installed
the roaring fireplace in the containment
cell and everyone who entered could
swear the cell looked many times bigger
than any other cell in the facility
scp-343 wasn't just breaking containment
he now seemed to be breaking the laws of
physics in the facility the rules of the
scp containment facility didn't seem to
be a concern to scp-343
but there was one thing he didn't seem
to want to do escape after every sudden
exit he would always return to his
personal cell and treat it as his home
when interviewed by staff members he was
polite but vague and everyone seemed to
enjoy talking to him it was decided to
keep him on site not attempt to increase
his security but restrict access and
keep his room guarded at all times to
ensure only researchers with level 3
access and above were allowed to meet
with him but god works in mysterious
ways minimal security site 17 was one of
the least restrictive scp containment
sites hosting anomalies that could be
safely contained and weren't likely to
mount violent escapes but as in every
scp facility security was still taken
seriously and only those with proper
clearance could interact with the
subjects so why did scp-343 seem
impossible to guard while only level 3
clearance and above were allowed in the
guards assigned to protect the entrance
all seemed to fall down on the job
security officer james who was supposed
to be keeping people out of scp-343 cell
had instead let in multiple visitors in
addition to dropping in several times
himself when questioned on why he had
gone against orders and done so he
simply replied that 343 seemed lonely
and was so happy every time he got
company that it just seemed like the
right thing to do the security guard was
reassigned and new ones were brought in
but history repeated itself guards were
given stricter instructions to minimize
exposure but
scp-343's presence always seemed to
influence them anyway his containment
cell was a revolving door with staff
members at the facility entering
regularly for friendly conversations dr
beck decided it was time to take matters
into his own hands he would meet with
scp-343 one-on-one and express how
dangerous these security breaches were
he would try to convince the mysterious
being that he needed to stop influencing
the minds of the guards watching him or
the facility would have to look into new
measures to contain him dr back entered
the containment cell and had a long
conversation with
scp-343 and when he emerged he had a big
smile on his face like he had just
finished a reunion with an old friend he
gave the current guard a friendly clap
on the back and told him not to worry so
much about security after all nothing
bad was gonna happen from letting people
at the facility visit scp-343 right he
wasn't dangerous in any way he also said
that security should bring him anything
he requests so he would feel less need
to leave a cell minimal security site 17
soon became a model scp facility with
morale being the highest of any site
with most giving the credit to the
presence of scp-343
employees generally make daily visits to
his chamber and he seems to have an
encyclopedic knowledge of anything they
want to talk about including things he
should have no way of knowing guards no
longer quit their posts or break
protocol as their only real duty is to
keep track of who meets with scp-343
so they can be interviewed and debriefed
after everyone's conversation is
different but they all report being in a
better mood after leaving than when they
came in no further information is
available on
scp-343's origins the full extent of his
powers or whether he is telling the
truth about being the god who created
the universe the site director rubbed
his temples after hearing the
researcher's explanation so what you're
telling me is that we have an
uncontained highly powerful scp that has
not only been breaking containment
whenever it wants but has managed to
destroy all the files regarding the
research on it the researcher's answer
was yes however the situation at site-17
seemed to be stable and they had come up
with a plan that should help to maximize
the positive effect
scp-343 has on the facility they were
even hypothesizing that staff from other
sites and even certain anomalies could
be pacified by 343's presence the site
director wasn't impressed though he
wanted the researcher to go back to the
drawing board and redo the research
after all if all the files were blank
how could they ever learn how to
properly contain it that's what the c
and scp stood for after all containment
the researcher finally had to stand to
the director though and told them that
it wasn't a good idea that they had
already tried everything to contain
scp-343
but that it wasn't that he broke
containment it was as if he didn't even
acknowledge that an attempt had been
made to contain him he was omnipotent
aware of things he shouldn't and able to
do things that broke the laws of physics
without breaking a sweat there was no
evidence that this was god the creator
of the universe as he claimed to be but
there also wasn't any evidence yet to
conclusively prove he wasn't the
researcher's best guess was that this
was a powerful reality bender whose
abilities knew no limits and that the
only reason he was staying in the
facility was because he wanted to and
doing anything to change that might
cause him to change his benevolent ways
the director's side as much as he hated
to admit it his researcher was making
good points he wanted to meet scp-343
personally but did he need to know
anything first well sir the researcher
replied he likes hamburgers but beyond
that he'll take care of the rest he's
right there where we left him in his
home waiting for his next cast
an scp foundation researcher sits at a
table inside of a standard containment
cell these are often dangerous places to
be
especially when the scp you're supposed
to be studying is one that you can't see
the researcher is taking notes unsure of
exactly what is going to happen next he
can hear the sounds of knives scraping
behind of flesh sizzling and searing
from high heat he braces himself as a
burst of heat hits the back of his head
as if a fireball has erupted an object
floats through the air and settles in
front of him on the table it's a plate
of food and it looks delicious
it may surprise you to learn that there
is no rule that the scp foundation must
deal exclusively with violent and
vicious creatures not every scp held in
containment shares the same malevolence
and contempt for humanity as scp-682
or the world-ending threat posed by the
likes of scp-2317
some perhaps not many but some are
benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the scp foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with scp-5031
as per the foundation's containment
procedures this quasi-humanoid meaning
it appears to have some vaguely human
features is held in an airtight cell
that is regularly checked by foundation
personnel on a bi-weekly basis
scp-5031 has no need for regular
nutrition or regular interactions from
staff the trick with scp-5031
is not being eaten by it
since though it doesn't need food it
does still hunt and consume anything it
encounters human or otherwise
avoiding being eaten is hard enough with
creatures that can actually be seen but
like so many other creatures the
foundation keeps contained
scp-5031 has developed an almost perfect
defense mechanism
which is when observed it will literally
cease to exist some might choose to
refer to this as a quantum lock however
it is worth noting that traces left by
scp-5031 still remain observable when
the creature has temporarily disappeared
for example trails of blood and scratch
marks left behind by scp-5031 still
exist when the scp itself does not
naturally this makes both avoiding the
creature and capturing it using cameras
difficult however when
scp-5031s exist existence ceases it
still casts a shadow from this
researchers have been able to determine
several of the creature's physical
traits
based on its silhouette it has been
deduced that scp-5031 levitates about
half a meter above ground level sports
an abnormally small necklace head atop
an elongated torso approximately 1.9
meters long
with three sets of spindly lower arms
that branch outwards using these arms
and its loosely hanging body
scp-5031 will lower itself to hunt any
human or animal that draws near to it
and uses the blade-like tail to cut up
food
perhaps the most interesting facet of
beyond its defensive capabilities and
apparent physical attributes
are the series of nine tests conducted
by senior researcher stanley huxtable
appalled by the conditions that the
creature was being kept in huxtable took
over the role of hcl supervisor for
scp-5031
having grown increasingly frustrated and
empathetic towards the creature
listening to its screams from inside its
iron containment unit huxtable devised a
series of tests to introduce scp-1531 to
various different stimuli as a way to
better understand the creature and
hopefully keep it contained in a way
that didn't seem to cause so much
suffering
it's worth remembering that the scp
foundation makes its mission to be cold
not cruel in performing their duties to
protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff
are just as capable of having empathy
for creatures as you might for a stray
animal at a shelter
the first of huxtables tests involved
installing speakers in scp-5031 cell
through which a variety of different
ambient and popular pieces of music were
played to see if they had any effect on
reducing the creature's stress by
judging
scp-5031 stress levels based on how much
it screened when compared to normal
huxtable was able to determine how to
best use music to calm the creature
scp-5031 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
forest deep grotto and seaside paradise
ambience
as well as the best of late 60s british
rock band jethro tull however the best
of mozart enya kiss and ben folds
produced dramatically different results
decreasing
scp-5031's apparent stress following
this test senior researcher huxtable
compiled a playlist featuring
scp-5031's favorite music over time the
stress-reducing effects of music on
scp-5031 seemed to decrease
but keeping the playlist on shuffles
seemed to keep the creature consistently
calmer than it had been previously
the next test involved introducing
inanimate objects into
scp-5031's enclosure to monitor its
reactions and how its stress levels were
affected
when a softball was thrown into the
enclosure
scp-5031 immediately sliced the ball in
two with its tail in one swift motion a
similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature of basketball which
was quickly punctured and sliced open by
scp-5031's tail its stress levels first
seemed to diminish when the creature was
offered a bowling ball which it rolled
around the enclosure and then later
knocked it against a second bowling ball
however when one of the balls chipped
rendering it unable to roll properly
scp-5031 stress increased dramatically
until a replacement was offered
researcher huxtable noted that scp-5031
seemed to possess a similar level of
motor skills to an average human toddler
with similarly explosive emotional
reactions to match
next when given the choice between two
food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure
scp-5031 seemed to gravitate towards
higher quality food most notably favored
cooked rotisserie chickens over animal
carcasses
it even chose this option over a live
chicken using its tail to cut its food
into more manageable bite-sized portions
rather than ripping its meat with its
hands or teeth like many of its fellow
scps
researcher huxtable recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though scp-5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive
providing the creature with food of a
better quality marginally reduced its
stress
senior researcher huxtable next
attempted to test
scp-5031's coexistence with other living
subjects
each time making sure that the creature
had been adequately fed to avoid any
unseemly incidents
first a live chicken was introduced
scp-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high
speed towards the chicken increasing
both its and the chicken's stress levels
and inadvertently killing the chicken in
the process
when a second chicken was introduced
scp-5031
gently rolled a basketball towards it
but ceased any further engagement after
the chicken squawked from being hit by
the ball next to be introduced into the
enclosure was a blindfolded d-class
staff member who was instructed to sit
down and roll the basketball towards
scp-5031
after doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject who was instructed to remove
their blindfold to cease the creature's
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxtable had another class d engage in a
game of catch with scp-5031
while facing away from the creature
this test proceeded successfully and
senior researcher huxtable remarked how
scp-5031's motor skills were improving
albeit gradually and with some gentle
encouragement through huxtable's tests
the creature was learning
the next test focused on teaching
scp-5031 linguistic symbols utilized lcd
displays and buttons connected to a food
dispenser one display showed an image of
a rock and the other an image of a
rotisserie chicken after some brief
probing
scp-5031 was quickly able to understand
that pressing the button under the
correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat the
creature was later able to adapt when
the following day the screen displays
and materials dispensed were swapped and
then later set to swap at random
intervals when additional rock
dispensing stations were introduced this
time displaying the word rock as opposed
to an image
scp-5031 was able to determine which
station dispensed chicken through a
process of elimination whenever the
functions and displays were swapped
scp-5031 would find whichever displayed
the word chicken to receive its food the
final phase of this test presented
scp-5031 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain inactive unless
the creature spelled out the same word
with a collection of lettered blocks it
was provided with after some initial
confusion and frustrations as to why the
button would not dispense food when
pressed
scp-5031 was able to assemble the word
correctly not only activating the button
and dispensing food but proving to
researcher huxtable that the creature
was capable of learning language
huxtable continued to test the creature
encouraging it to spell words using
lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing scp-5031's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received
senior researcher huxtable observed that
scp-5031 was gradually learning to sing
albeit non-verbally as well as to juggle
with its six hands and was even
communicating its food preferences and
dish pairings
later another class d d52125
was introduced to
scp-5031's enclosure to aid in further
testing through
d52125's instructions the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons
and created artworks depicting itself
its newfound friend d52125
researcher huxtable a cat and a
rotisserie chicken
scp-5031's new creative side didn't stop
there though as the creature quickly
learned to play chopsticks in only two
days once a piano was introduced into
the enclosure
scp-5031 even managed to start creating
its own original admittedly crude
compositions
next a spice rack was placed inside the
creature's cell and d-52125 demonstrated
how to season mead this proved to be
scp-5031's new favorite hobby as it
spent the next three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and
spices
using its letter blocks to request more
more more garlic powder interestingly
the creature only created artwork or
music when
d52125 was present but seemed to
thoroughly enjoy its experimentation
with food when left alone
following this development senior
researcher huxtable devised a new test
for scp-5031
providing the creature with cooking
utensils and using
d52125 to demonstrate 5031 was shown how
to prepare a variety of different dishes
from hamburgers and tacos to mongolian
beef steak clam chowder and profiteroles
in addition to a small peanut allergy
this eighth test revealed
scp-5031 to be a phenomenal chef
possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person the creature quickly
and enthusiastically embraced its
newfound talents concocting its very own
brand new recipes with d52125
even volunteering to be the first to
taste test 5031's dishes it was shortly
after this test that
scp-5031 spoke its very first word
and it should come as no surprise that
the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxtable was
very proud of the progress the creature
had made with its development
the final test almost seemed to be what
the creature was born for over the
course of two months scp-5031 was tasked
with creating a full three-course meal
which would then be served to foundation
staff for thanksgiving
scp-5031 not only rose to the task but
exceeded all of researcher huxtable's
expectations creating a meal that even
gordon ramsay would be hard-pressed to
find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric
next came a beautiful duck confit glazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped
generously with sweet cranberry compote
paired with a side of butternut squash
gnocchi and served on a bed of kale
seasoned with truffle salt the grand
finale of the exquisite meal was a
spiced cassava pie for dessert
complemented with the finest french
vanilla ice cream and a maple hazelnut
syrup
and scp-5031 didn't stop there the
creature also debuted one of its
original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
scp-5031
performed live from its enclosure the
deeply moving piano concerto for six
hands to an overwhelmingly positive
response from not only senior researcher
huxtable but the entire foundation staff
as a fitting end to the creature's tail
huxtable reported that during the
thanksgiving banquet it had created
scp-5031 stress levels reduced entirely
new kinder containment measures that
would keep 5031 safer but also far more
contented were submitted for approval
perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that scp-5031
isn't simply just another malicious
malevolent monster that the foundation
has to keep under lock and key for the
safety of the world
instead
scp-5031 is a gentle if a little
frightening at first creature that just
requires careful and considered guidance
instead of a cold iron cage and
around-the-clock arm guards through
testing senior researchers stanley
huxtable and his fellow foundation staff
were not only able to help the creature
develop but also found what makes it
tick and not just for the purposes of
containing it instead it is hoped that
scp-5031's creativity and flair for
culinary and musical masterpieces can
continue to thrive and grow
under the proud watch of researcher
huxtable
in an old house an old woman gathers her
knitting supplies
this is a special project for a little
boy named tommy she loves dearly she
knits furiously and soon the mix of
cotton synthetic fiber and cloth of
every color turn from raw materials into
something else a teddy bear she puts the
finishing touches on the bear this is a
very special bear after all and sends
the patchwork bear off to its
destination with a red get well card the
card is labeled k rose the bear and
inside she writes a personal note to
tommy because only time can mend all
wounds love grammy but this package of
love would never reach its destination
scp-2295 was found at the site of a
crashed mail truck and it looks exactly
like a standard handmade teddy bear with
one difference on the left side of its
chest just under its jaunty tan bow it
wears a heart-shaped pin but not a
standard cartoon heart this is a
disturbingly realistic anatomically
correct pin of a heart organ and that's
because
scp-2295 has a specific purpose and it's
one that has everything to do with
actual human organs
scp-2295 spends most of its time
completely inert spending its days as
just another cuddly stuffed toy tests
performed on the toy revealed that it
had no unusual properties and seems to
be a normal handmade keepsake that is
until someone is injured in its presence
not any injury will do a paper cut or
even a broken arm for example won't do
much to activate its anomalous
properties but if it detects a critical
injury to a human organ nearby it will
trigger a secret power one that the
foundation is still trying to figure out
how it works because scp-2295
is a miracle worker when it senses the
presence of someone with a serious
injury to an organ and is within two
meters of them scp-2295
springs into action suddenly from
unknown sources the bear will produce
objects including scissors white thread
and sewing needles or a crocheting hook
from its mouth if there are any crafting
supplies on hand it will incorporate
those as well and then it gets to work
despite only having hands made of fabric
and stuffing with no fingers the
anomalous bearer is still able to craft
what will end up being a patchwork
recreation of the damaged human's organ
cute if a little creepy but that's just
the beginning the injured person
mysteriously falls unconscious and the
patchwork organ which the foundation has
designated as
scp-2295-1 instance will disappear the
scp-2295-1 instance will then physically
replace the damaged organ inside the
person's body it's unknown how this
happens the patchwork organ will simply
appear inside of their body taking the
place of the original lung or kidney or
whichever organ was failing it's unknown
where the original organ goes to since
it seems to just disappear as soon as
the
2295-1 instance takes its place
surprisingly having this new
cotton-stuffed heart or liver does not
seem to cause any harm and in fact it
works exactly like the real thing there
are never any of the usual issues that
come with a transplant like the risk of
it being rejected by the body as the
organic tissue seems to have no issue
connecting with the organ and treating
it like it was there all along in all
instances of scp-2295
performing this adorable but rudimentary
surgery the subjects have made a full
and complete recovery
scp-2295 might sound like a miracle
worker but that isn't to say that its
abilities aren't without their own set
of complications when faced with two
injured subjects
scp-2295 seems to always gravitate
towards fixing the younger subject up
first maybe owing to its creation by a
grandmother who wanted to heal whatever
was ailing her grandson no one knows who
tommy was or exactly what disease or
injury he was recovering from but his
grandmother clearly felt it was serious
enough to create this special bear for
him while
scp-2295 will heal anyone it seems to be
primarily a guardian for the young and
it takes its duties very seriously even
to the point of self-sacrifice while
scp-2295 is able to pull some of its
supplies out of thin air it still always
needs some raw materials to craft the
new organ including fabric and stuffing
and if there are none available
scp-2295 will obtain them the hard way
the patchwork bear will sacrifice its
own body tearing itself open and
removing any fabric or stuffing it needs
without any concern for its own
well-being in order to craft a new organ
for its patient it slowly regenerates
its own stuffing at the rate of around a
gram of stuffing per day but it needs to
harvest fabric to repair its outer layer
which the foundation happily makes
available to it offering it a variety of
patterns and types it's no surprise that
a teddy bear capable of healing mortal
wounds would be of great interest to the
scp foundation and as soon as it was
recovered from the crash mail truck they
immediately began tests to find out more
about it could it heal literally any
organ were there any limits to its
abilities there was only one way to find
out and the foundation had the perfect
test subjects d-class personnel whose
interactions with non-cuddly teddy bear
scps frequently left them with critical
external and internal injuries the first
test subject brought in d 2353 a 38 year
old man who was in poor health not due
to his work as a d-class personnel but
from his years and years of heavy
smoking his lungs were seriously damaged
which gave him trouble breathing and
made any serious physical exertion
extremely difficult he wasn't critically
injured or in danger of dying
immediately but that didn't matter to
scp-2295
d-2353 quickly passed out and the bear
sprang into action he proceeded to take
two textile swatches one black and one
red and create a pair of fabric lungs
which it installed in the patient when
he awoke d 2353 found he had full
healthy lung function again as if he
never picked up his deadly habit but now
the foundation researchers needed to
know how
scp-2295 would do with even more
complicated ailments d3542
was 50 years old and his heart was not
in good shape not only did he have a
serious case of atherosclerosis which is
a disease where cholesterol plaque
builds up and blocks blood flow and can
put you at serious risk of a heart
attack but he also had an irregular
heartbeat this d-class was in bad shape
but that was no problem for scp-2295
who took a collection of different
colors of yarn and a crochet hook and
created a plushy heart just like the
lungs had acted as if they were
completely regular organs after the
heart anomalously ended up inside the
man's chest it began to beat normally
and performed all the complicated
functions of a human heart but there was
one detail that shocked the onlooking
doctors before the yarn organ had
vanished the doctors had seen that it
was beating so is there any organ that
scp-2295 can't replace that was about to
be tested when
d7894 was brought in a 24 year old woman
she had suffered serious burns all over
her torso left abdomen and right leg she
was brought in and sedated to numb the
agonizing pain and researchers were
worried that they had come up against
the limit of
scp-2295's abilities since the skin is
the largest organ after all but
scp-2295 wasn't phased at all the bear
immediately started sewing segments of
patchwork fabric and layering them onto
the damaged skin replacing the dermis
and epidermis layer by layer unlike the
other cases these replacement organs are
visible and
d7894 now has patchwork skin just like
her talented surgeon and amazingly the
fabric has the same sense of touch that
her regular skin did the final test of
scp-2295's abilities came with d-2723
who was only 18 years old this last
minute d-class test was performed
because he was showing signs of severe
cerebral hemorrhage the kind that would
cause brain damage in only minutes and
would be followed soon after by complete
brain death
scp-2295 sprung to life but as soon as
it examined the test subject it became
distressed it started frantically
grasping at random material around it as
if it didn't know what to do with them
then it reached inside itself and
provided a large chocolate bar which it
offered to the subject sadly to no
effect it then seemed to admit defeat as
it grabbed tightly onto the subject's
leg observers reported that it was
leaking a tear-like solution from its
small knitted eyes as it embraced the
dying d-class in his final moments sadly
it seems that the human brain is the one
mystery that even scp-2295
can't solve
scp-2295 appears to pose no threat to
anyone and was classified as safe after
testing it is inactive when not in the
presence of an injured person and has
never displayed hostile instincts when
active the foundation determined that it
should be stored in a standard
containment locker in site-37 where it
can be kept safely until it's needed for
tests or to repair an injured scp
personnel access is limited to those
with level 3 or higher security
clearance and any contact with the bear
is highly regulated but there is one
element of
scp-2295's existence that continues to
worry foundation staff
scp-2295's full origins and the
grandmother who crafted it are unknown
the note it was found with is the only
clue as to where it may have come from
but there are plenty within the
foundation who are suspicious of the
veracity of this letter and they have
good reason not to be too trusting
because another bear with similar
abilities exists and it is distinctly
less benevolent than scp-2295
scp-1048 is also a teddy bear but it is
capable of moving on its own and
communicating through gestures at all
times it was initially allowed to wander
around independently and seemed to make
its home at site-24 a happier place but
then it began to display its own
crafting abilities
scp-1048 is able to craft duplicates of
itself and while the original was
seemingly harmless the ones it made were
not these similarly shaped bears were
made of disturbing materials and were
extremely hostile towards any humans
they encountered the first scp-1048-a
was made entirely out of human ears and
when it shrieked it caused anyone nearby
to generate ear-like growths all over
their bodies eventually causing them to
suffocate the creature disappeared and
an on-site researcher was found to be
missing an ear the creations of scp-1048
only got stranger and deadlier from
there scp-1048-b
was found in the site's cafeteria where
it was moving around in a halted jerky
fashion it then started bursting at the
seams and revealed what appeared to be a
human fetus inside when the creature
screamed it sounded like a much louder
version of a human infant and its crows
caused massive internal damage to anyone
around it
scp-1048-b was killed in the ensuing
conflict with foundation agents ending
its threat but scp-1048 was learning
deadlier techniques when
scp-1048-c was discovered it looked to
be a teddy bear made entirely out of
rusty scrap metal when it was spotted by
dr carver and targeted by foundation
personnel the creature turned violent
and proved to have incredible strength
jumping through the agents who were
trying to neutralize it tearing through
their bodies like tissue paper attempts
to damage it were unsuccessful and both
it and the bear made out of ears are
still on the loose along with the
original scp-1048
capturing it is major priority for the
foundation because no one wants to see
what it will create next is there a
connection between these two very
different teddy bears no one has been
able to answer this question the origins
of scp-1048 are unknown and so is any
connection to the mysterious grandmother
who may have made k-rose the bear but
their abilities are similar with both
able to craft living objects out of
seemingly any material they just have
very different ideas as to what a good
use of their crafting abilities are it
is fortunate that an anomaly is
potentially powerful as scp-2290
seems to only want one thing to help
those in need especially those who are
the most vulnerable
they'd spent hours making the costume
the two young boys let's call them
johnny and max had always been on the
creative side sometimes they got teased
for it at school but they didn't care as
long as they had each other they could
handle anything they were best friends
maybe one day they'd build great things
together out of concrete and steel but
for now they worked with cardboard prior
projects had included building a rocket
out of cardboard in johnny's backyard
like the kind that put a man on the moon
they'd also made a box forth like no
other more a box castle really the kind
that would stand for a hundred years as
long as it didn't rain of course but all
of that felt like nothing compared to
the tunnel monster to these two young
friends it was a thing of beauty a fully
articulated cardboard monster costume
meticulously cobbled together from boxes
masking tape cardboard tubes for arms
and legs and a little twine to bring it
all together frankenstein dracula freddy
krueger those silver screen phonies were
nothing compared to the tunnel monster
they even cut out eye holes in the head
and drew the scariest snarling mouth
that they could write below the making
was over and now they were ready to play
johnny and max took the costume down to
one of their favorite places in town the
abandoned brechter construction site to
many would seem like a strange and
dangerous place for two young children
to play but for johnny and max it was
perfect after all they were the age
where they had more imagination than
sense max would be the one wearing the
costume johnny helped him put it on
piece by piece using extra masking tape
and twine where necessary to fasten all
the pieces together
little by little max became the tunnel
monster the transformation was complete
and it was finally time for the games to
begin johnny ran wielding a stick as a
defensive weapon while max gave chase he
could feel his own hot breath within the
cardboard mask it was oddly exhilarating
he gave a monstrous roar and charged
after his friend chasing him into the
child-sized pipes of an unfinished water
drainage system it was more fun than
anything they could have imagined max
really got into his role he lunged
forwards grabbing johnny with his
cardboard gauntlets and tried to drag
him back into the tunnel all while
giving low guttural growls johnny
laughed and swatted at max with his
stick like a knight wielding a sword
they ran and crawled through the tunnels
the best of friends having the best of
times making the kind of memories that
would last forever and in that sense
they were right something they made that
day would echo on forever but it
wouldn't be something they would look
back upon fondly if they weren't so busy
running through the tunnels max and
johnny might have noticed that something
was amiss they might have seen that even
though it was only 3 p.m on a summer's
day the sky was beginning to darken it
may not have saved them but it might
have given them time to prepare for what
was coming max was still chasing johnny
down a pipe still fully in character as
the tunnel monster his arms extended to
grab his fleeing friend while johnny
tripped max stopped to help him up but
something was wrong when max helped
johnny stand up johnny instinctually
pushed him away as though it wasn't
actually his friend anymore
max stumbled backwards in shock and
horror he could feel something changing
beneath the cardboard he suddenly was in
pain this terrible pain like he was
being pulled apart and put back together
he started to scream it was a horrible
sound like nails on a chalkboard johnny
had to hold his ears as the screaming
got louder and louder but max couldn't
stop he was hurting too much to stop
johnny was crying he didn't know what
was happening only that his friend was
in terrible pain and that there was
seemingly nothing he could do to stop it
even max didn't know much more than that
but he thought it might have something
to do with the suit it felt like it was
full of fire ants crawling and biting it
felt like his body was full of fire ants
he needed to take the suit off before it
got any worse but he couldn't the suit
wouldn't come off he reached for the
cardboard mask and tried to tug it off
his head but it wouldn't budge he felt
like he was tugging at the skin of his
own face he could suddenly feel
everything that brushed against the
cardboard like it was connected to his
nerve endings the fear and the panic got
worse and he kept screaming it was a
deafening ear splitting screen he didn't
know it but anything electrical within a
200 meter radius was dying tvs shut off
radios fizzled out cars stopped running
nobody who didn't work for the scp
foundation would ever know why it wasn't
even 3 30 p.m but the sky above looked
black as midnight max was afraid but all
he could do was cling to the familiar he
lunged forwards and grabbed johnny
pulling him into his trembling embrace
is he still max now no he doesn't think
so anymore he's something else entirely
as he held his friend max tried to dig
his fingers into the mask and tear it
off
they pierced through the cardboard
tearing holes into it it was agonizing
but the mask stayed put there was no
escape he closed his eyes just for a
moment maybe it was a bad dream maybe he
could make it disappear but it didn't
disappear only he did max was no more
there was only the tunnel monster when
johnny woke up he was disoriented and
afraid he was in complete darkness but
he could feel the old metal of a rusty
railroad track beneath his feet he
didn't remember how he got there and he
didn't remember max either not his face
or even his name but that's alright max
didn't remember him either when the
terrified johnny eventually found his
way out of the old railway tunnel he'd
somehow found himself in he was rescued
by emergency services and treated for
dehydration because of the incredibly
strange circumstances of his
disappearance and reappearance over 4
000 kilometers away it was only natural
for the scp foundation to check in but
seeing as johnny had no memory of where
he was or who he was with prior to his
mysterious teleportation all they ever
did was investigate the tunnel he'd
appear in of course they didn't find a
thing the case was closed shortly
afterwards written off as a kind of
one-off spatial anomaly johnny was given
an amnestic treatment and reintegrated
back into his normal life he would never
remember his encounter with the tunnel
monster but many would for decades and
decades to come there would be stories
and scattered witness accounts from all
kinds of people maintenance workers
doing electrical repairs on subway
tunnels sewer workers cleaning up
blockages in pipes road workers fixing
the asphalt in underpasses the challenge
with being an scp foundation field agent
is often separating the genuine leads
from the urban legends and spooky's
stories but the details here were all
too similar and specific after all it
would be such a strange thing to make up
a moldy old pile of cardboard boxes
getting up and running towards you but
stranger still these incidents and
encounters were occurring all over the
united states with the only
commonalities being that all of them
happened in tunnels or tunnel-like
structures the foundation didn't know if
they were dealing with one entity or
many another peculiar factor they
observed was that sometimes people who
had encounters with the tunnel monster
then themselves appear in tunnels
extremely far away from the ones in
which they first encountered it as far
as the foundation was aware besides
transporting them vast distances it
never actually harmed any of its victims
but according to one boston sewer worker
gus segrelia when the tunnel monster
laid its cardboard hand on him he felt
the most profound sense of paranoia and
dread he described it as feeling like a
thousand eyes in the dark watching you
die then he blinked and he woke up in an
arizona viaduct roughly six hours later
everyone who reported a similar
experience with the tunnel monster was
detained debriefed and given amnestics
by the foundation eventually they
gathered enough data on prior encounters
to accurately predict the next tunnel
that the tunnel monster would manifest
inside a new mobile task force was
formed to secure the creature mtf new 4
also known as the box cutters what they
didn't expect was that when they finally
engaged the beast was that it was no
larger than a human child it wasn't some
huge tunnel dwelling nightmare even
after all these decades the tunnel
monster was little more than a
frightened lonely little boy he growled
attempting and failing to come off as
intimidating to these hardcore mtf
members and referred to himself as the
tunnel monster when they didn't react
with fear and surprise like the others
he became subdued they were able to
peacefully apprehend him and take him
back to site 54 for testing and
containment preliminary x-rays found
that the cardboard costume hadn't just
fused with the boy it had completely
transformed him on the inside he was
filled with crude cardboard copies of
all the major internal organs with his
blood vessels and nerve endings made out
of colored pieces of string they
couldn't find any information on who the
boy was if he had ever been a boy at all
and he was given the designation
scp-3663 in order to find out more one
of the leading researchers on the
scp-3663 case researcher doyle decided
to conduct an interview with the tunnel
monster it had been the only interview
with the creature to date due to the
emotional distress it caused the
creature when asked about its identity
it replied with only the tunnel monster
when asked why it attacked and
teleported people to different locations
the creature replied the tunnel monster
captures people that's me
i'm the tunnel monster i capture people
and take them into the tunnels where i
live in the tunnels the pipes i'm the
tunnel monster as the interview
progressed the tunnel monster became
increasingly upset until it began
weeping through its cardboard face
finally culminating with its crying out
between sobs please i don't want to play
anymore scp-3663
only feels comfortable in tunnels and
will teleport away in distress if
confined anywhere else as such its
containment chamber is technically the
maintenance tunnels underneath site 54
where it seems to have made a home for
itself occasionally if it experiences
fear damage or stress it may demanifest
and appear in tunnels elsewhere at that
point the box cutters are deployed to
collect 3663 once again and bring him
back to site 54. so far there has only
been one major containment breach with
scp-3663
but it was a little more deadly than you
might expect for a boy-sized creature
made of cardboard the tunnel monster
escaped from the site-54 tunnels and
began wailing in pain it went positively
berserk attacking surrounding staff and
trashing parts of the facility anyone
who heard the whales of the tunnel
monster reported becoming extremely
psychologically disturbed by them during
this 4-hour rampage the monster also
tried multiple times to destroy itself
with various implements but was
unsuccessful after
scp-3663 was recontained two deceased
members of personnel were recovered from
the scene autopsy showed the cause of
death was a buildup of paper residue and
wood pulp in all of their major blood
vessels as well as sinuses ear tubes and
the majority of the digestive and
respiratory systems a number of other
staff members were found to have been
affected to a lesser degree but are
expected to make full recoveries what
triggered this explosive and deadly
outburst not even the tunnel monster
itself knew the answer to this question
but we do
at exactly the same time a 79 year old
man passed away from natural causes
after what seemed like a thoroughly
unremarkable life that man's name was
johnny
think back to your childhood and ask
yourself what was the most pain you've
ever felt while growing up as we develop
our understanding of pain evolves
according to our different experiences
the older we get the injuries we
suffered as children like a scraped knee
or a bee sting rarely cause us the same
level of distress as they used to of
course when you are young and unfamiliar
with sensations of pain what you really
need in that moment straight after
you've fallen off your bike or tripped
playing soccer is someone to pick you
back up and give your sore spot a kiss
perhaps you even need a bowl of warm
soup to comfort you luckily for you
scp-348
is exactly that while many of the
anomalies held in containment by the scp
foundation have earned the euclid or
infamous ketter class designations
scp-348 is one of the few considered to
be safe both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
eldritch abomination from another
dimension spreading its influence in our
world through mimetic stimuli nor is it
a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the garden of eden to put it simply
scp-348
is a bull a white ceramic bowl the kind
you would find almost anywhere in the
world it may even look indistinguishable
from the one in your kitchen cabinet of
course scp-348 is hardly as ordinary as
it outwardly appears to be and it
certainly isn't the only inanimate
object that the foundation keeps safely
stored away the key thing that
differentiates scp-348 from most other
anomalies is how genuinely harmless it
is its anomalous properties do not cause
injury to any individual that interacts
with it nor does this bowl have any
adverse effects on the world around it
scp-348 cannot bend or reshape reality
it does not cause the person eating from
it to have premonitions of their own
death and using it certainly does not
manifest a contract-making entity at the
opposite side of the table so what makes
this bowl in any way anomalous what
about it categorizes it as an scp and
not just a harmless piece of fine
crockery well why don't we start with
how scp-348 was first discovered some
time ago the scp foundation was made
aware of rumors surrounding a child
living in an unknown part of the world
according to the intelligence gathered
by the foundation this child seemed to
possess some sort of healing ability or
at least this is what rumors suggested
upon further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as
scp-348 this is not to say that the bowl
has any inherently supernatural healing
properties and it doesn't impart any
regenerative power to those that eat
from it either it does heal in a certain
sense but not in the way you're probably
imagining when the scp foundation
recovered scp-348
there were no markings on it indicating
where the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand-painted around both the inside and
outside of
scp-348 the ceramic surface also bore
the chinese letters shangshini which
translates to the phrase thinking of you
the child that first discovered it found
the ceramic bowl in the attic of their
home the child's parents were both
full-time workers and seemed to be
somewhat neglectful of their child
although they refused to comment on this
but according to the findings of the scp
foundation the child had come to rely on
scp-348
deciding to further investigate the
anomalous properties of scp-348
the foundation began testing it given
that the child who first discovered the
bull had relied upon it tests involved
foundation researchers presenting
certain children to scp-348 and
observing the results so was this bowl
haunted perhaps harboring some malicious
spirit or entity that sought to corrupt
these children maybe even healing them
in order to somehow use them as a vessel
to break into our world no and while may
have not healed in any overt or expected
way it did heal in at least a
metaphorical sense if presented with an
injured child sporting any form of minor
ailments such as a cut or a runny nose
scp-348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you
may ask well that seems to vary
sometimes it is tomato soup other times
it might be chicken noodle soup while
the ingredients used in the soups are
often different there are notable
consistencies to how scp-348 heals if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered bowl then scp-348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finishing the entire bowl
when permitted to by research staff many
of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from
scp-348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises
some even claimed that even though they
were in a room all alone they didn't
feel lonely when they were eating the
soup and all the anomalous properties
don't end after a child finishes the
soup usually although not always the
bowl will leave the child a message
often some brief words of reassurance or
comfort these messages materialize on
the inside rim of the bowl and seem to
be specifically tailored to the subject
that has just eaten the words will not
only be written in the child's first
language but are often linked to the
child's home life or relationship with
their parents messages that appear on
scp-348 usually fade over time normally
disappearing after a few hours or when
the bowl refills with more soup one test
of scp-348 saw a little girl age eight
and suffering from a sore throat brought
before the bowl according to a
background screening made by research
personnel the girl lived with her
biological parents and apparently had a
good relationship with both her mother
and her father when scp-348 filled with
soup for her the girl took almost half
an hour to finish eating and afterwards
reported that she felt her sore throat
get better as she ain't by the end of
the meal this test subject remarked that
she felt completely normal in this
instance no message appeared within the
bowl another child was brought in to
continue the testing of scp-348
this time a boy of 10 unlike the
previous test this boy was not on good
terms with his parents and often argued
with them at the time of testing the boy
had sustained several minor bruises the
result of a small accident that occurred
while the boy had been out riding his
bike much like the little girl this
subject ate the suit that scp-348
presented him with this time though the
bull offered a message to the boy the
lettering found on the ceramic surface
of scp-348 simply read don't forget to
brush messages also appeared when an 11
year old boy with a slight cold ate soup
from the bowl this child had been
adopted by a foster family and after
eating from scp-348 he saw the message
i'm glad you're happy appear another
young test subject a boy aged six had a
similar experience in this instance the
child had several scrapes and scratches
from playing with his friends his
parents had divorced and he was living
with his mother at the time of testing
this time scp-348's message to this boy
read i'm sorry son a seven-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before scp-348
she had lost her father to a traffic
accident some time before testing
commenced and received the message i
love you after finishing her soup
further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from scp-348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
scp-348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seem to be faded not the clear
hand-painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of scp-348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
with some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of this woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some career training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the scp-348 testing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became
estranged from her parents over the
years but unlike the previous test this
woman had taken it upon herself to not
only send money to her parents but also
arranged senior care for both as well
prior to testing her father had died
peacefully of natural causes after
spending his last days in the care that
this woman had paid for as the woman ate
the soup from the bowl she remarked
about its apparently bitter taste but
also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank
you appeared within scp-348
one other adult subject that produced a
noticeable result from scp-348 was a 40
year old male the results of this test
appeared to be the most distinctly
different from any previous adult or
child by now researchers working for the
scp foundation had determined that
familial history seemed to play an
important role in the outcome of any
interaction with scp-348
and this individual was certainly
different to most the man in question
had murdered his father roughly a year
before the testing took place he began
the test with scp-348 while afflicted
with aches in his back after one taste
of the soup that appeared in the bowl
before him the murderer was immediately
repulsed he complained about the taste
refusing to eat any more from scp-348
shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but scp-348 immediately filled with
salt water which took three hours to
disappear from the ball despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the scp
foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in
scp-340
some are theorized because of the family
histories of some children and adults
tested that the words somehow come from
the father of whoever eats the soup
since even when a subject's father is
alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of scp-348
to provide comfort to small children
dealing with pain both inside and out
after all isn't providing comfort what a
good ball of soup anomalous or not is
best at
almost all cross-testing to kill or
pacify scp-682 had failed miserably if
you haven't seen it go watch our video
on the legendary hard to kill reptile
to see just how powerful and terrifying
this creature is it faced the gate
guardian an scp with a flaming sword
hotter than the sun
capable of tearing your atoms to shreds
and came out fine in its face off with a
horrifying scp-096
also known as the shy guy it broke the
shy guy's mind and reduced it to
jibbering despair even as cps would
supposedly unlimited powers simply
refused to engage the beast in combat
so when it was proposed that they test
682 with scp-999
a creature known among foundation staff
as the tickle monster the idea was
considered laughable 682 had been burned
suffocated cut up incinerated and
growled in the faces of the gods how
could this so-called tickle monster ever
hope to survive an encounter let alone
win a fight
some even believe that this was the last
we'd see of scp-999
but what makes this story truly
remarkable is that that isn't how this
played out as you'll soon discover
scp-999 is an amazing and unique scp in
and of itself
but its secret origins and its
interactions with some other prominent
figures in the scp universe are what
make this humble slimy creature beyond
extraordinary
prepare yourself for the heartwarming
yes you heard that right the
heartwarming story of scp-999
several highly trained agents on 682
detail placed 999 into the immortal
lizard cell compared to the giant
reptilian sitting across from it 999
wasn't much to look at it's a large
orange amorphous blob of anomalous slime
weighing in at around 120 pounds scp-999
was nothing compared to the monstrosity
it was supposed to face while its weight
has in the past caused minor injuries to
some of its human handlers it has never
caused serious or long-lasting damage of
any kind to a living thing even its diet
consists only of candy and sweets with a
particular preference for m m's and
necco wafers it consumes these treats
through the cell membrane of its slimy
body much like an amoeba this extremely
stretchy membrane means the creature is
highly malleable including the ability
to stretch and flatten itself out to a
mere two centimeters thick at rest the
creature takes a dome-like shape around
two meters wide and one meter in height
the closest things the creature has to
limbs are pre-henso pseudopods those are
the arm-like projections normally seen
on single-celled organisms of which it
has at least three
the more you hear about this utterly
harmless creature the more that matching
it up with the pure embodiment of
absolute hatred known as scp-682 feels
downright cruel in absolute contrast to
the misanthropic attitudes of the
reptile 999 loves humans it has a
playful dog-like attitude much like an
over-excited puppy when approached 999
will react with extreme joy and slither
towards the nearest person in order to
interact
it will leap onto them using two of its
three prehensile pseudopods to hug the
person while the third nuzzles the
person's face emitting high-pitched
cooing and gurgling noises throughout
the creature is apparently pleasant in
every conceivable fashion as even its
odor has been reported to smell just
like the favorite scent of whoever is
smelling it
examples have included chocolate fresh
laundry bacon roses and play-doh
it's almost impossible to oversell just
how beloved and benevolent this strange
creature is it's one of the rare sapient
scps to earn the safe class and it's
allowed to roam freely around its
facility at all times apart from a
one-hour bedtime period between 8 and 9
pm in the rare instances that 999 has
caused harm to a worker at the facility
it immediately began to back away and
contract its body while whimpering in a
kind of dog-like apology
the closest the foundation has ever come
to having a real incident with the
creature was the time someone
accidentally fed it a can of caffeinated
cola causing it to become hyper for an
hour before becoming visibly queasy
you'll be relieved to know that it's
since made a full recovery
but what would happen when this
whimsical creature is forced to go
toe-to-toe with the foundation's most
ill-tempered monster the employees
observing the test watched in suspense
as 999 began to enthusiastically slither
towards 682 it's no surprise that after
being tortured and almost killed
hundreds of times during testing 682 had
grown jaded to the cross test it was
regularly subjected to when it saw this
strange orange blob squelching across
the ground towards it it sighed and
groaned expecting the worst
what is that the creature asked of its
gelatinous guest
scp-999 began jumping up and down in
front of 682 like an excited puppy
creating a high-pitched squealing noise
just as it regarded all living things
682 thought the creature bouncing around
before it was disgusting and hardly
worth the effort to destroy was the
foundation even trying anymore with a
single vicious stomp 682 flattened the
friendly creature beneath one of its
feet observers were prepared to charge
in and liberate 999 from under 682's
claws but then something truly
unexpected happened the expression on
682's acid eaten face began to slowly
change
it was beginning to smile observers
recorded a noise what they thought could
have been a chuckle as the creature
growled and said
what is this
i feel
good
while the observers looked on stunned at
what was happening 999 began to slither
and crawl up from between 682's toes
reformed on its scaly leg and slithered
up along its side until it reached the
neck there it began to nuzzle like it
had never nuzzled before
the results spoke for themselves 682 was
grinning and chuckling repeating a
phrase that the foundation never would
have imagined coming from 682
feels so
happy
happy
happy
happy
just when you thought scp-999 couldn't
possibly be more adorable you learn
about its greatest power bringing joy
anyone and anything that comes into
contact with the creature even in
passing will experience a kind of mild
euphoria as once contact with the
creature is prolonged this overwhelming
sense of joy increases and continues
long after you've separated from it
prolonged contact has completely cured
depression anxiety and ptsd along with a
number of other conditions including
rage and antisocial personality
disorders serial killers practically
become saints after coming into
prolonged contact with 999 and in that
moment 682 was no exception and there
truly does not appear to be no
exceptions while causing happiness and
joy isn't a dangerous weapon when it
comes to scp-999 it is an extremely
powerful one and what's more
scp-999 also appears to have an innate
sense for those who need its help most
with a particular affection for the hurt
and the unhappy the creature appears to
be a true altruist on a fundamental
level even risking its own safety to
help humans during dangerous containment
breaches in one dramatic instance 999
leaped into the air to block a bullet
from making contact with a member of
staff
as a result the creature is pretty much
universally loved by all members of
foundation staff it's the one scp who
has never made trouble for anyone back
in scp-682's containment cell the beast
was still smiling and laughing as 999
rubbed against its neck it was an event
so strange so unprecedented that the
observers in attendance felt like they
were hallucinating for a few minutes the
monster kept dreamily repeating the word
happy but then suddenly the creature
began to enter a fit of uncontrollable
booming laughter
it rolled onto its back slamming its
huge tail against the door it had just
fallen victim to one of 999's favorite
pastimes
tickle fights hence how it earned its
tickle monster nickname among staff
the tickle fight continued until 682
appeared to tire and fall asleep with a
smile still on its face
after 15 minutes of inactivity two
d-class personnel were commanded to
enter and retrieve scp-999 from the
containment cell they did so
successfully but as soon as 999 was
removed 682 roused from its lumber and
released a powerful psychic attack from
its entire body while laughing
maniacally it rendered all personnel
within a certain distance incapacitated
as they collapsed in fits of laughter
allowing 682 to escape and go on a
violent rampage
however in spite of this 999 showed no
fear and helped save some of the
bystanders as security officers subdued
and recaptured 682 and even after all of
this 999 showed no hard feelings towards
682 and indicated a desire to play again
it's a creature whose capacity for love
is so limitless that it's practically
immune to fear which is all well and
good because the true enemy that 999 is
destined to face is infinitely more
powerful and terrifying than 682 could
ever hope to be
what is this monster and why should 999
have to face it someday the answers to
these questions all lie in the true
origins of
scp-999 available only to those with
level 5 clearance and beyond
it's a perfect example of how something
good can come from the darkest places
there would be no scp-999 without
scp-231-7
scp-231 was a collection of seven girls
all impregnated by horrific nightmares
in a ritual performed by a cult known as
the children of the scarlet king
each of these girls over the years that
followed gave birth to some of the most
horrific monsters imaginable
one of which according to some was
scp-682
these beings were manifested by the
scarlet king a powerful interdimensional
nightmare god believed to be behind a
great deal of the darkness and horror
present within r and many other
dimensions foundation higher-ups have
declared the scarlet king to be the
greatest existing threat to the
multiverse at large
and
scp-231 was his latest direct
interaction with our universe
the only surviving member of scp-231
scp-231-7 gave birth in secret but she
didn't give birth to a monster she gave
birth to scp-999
a being of pure goodness that's right
the nicest kindest cuddliest scp of all
is the direct descendant of a being
that's essentially the dark god of all
evil feel free to take a moment to
absorb that
the creature even healed the girl who
birthed it and allowed her to return to
normal life with her family once more
from its first moments scp-999 was
making positive changes to the world
around it and according to ancient texts
from a scarlet king aligned culture
known as the devas
scp-999 is still very much in its
infancy yet it already has the power to
pacify its monstrous siblings like the
aforementioned 682
it's believed according to some
prophecies and foundation theories that
the power of scp-999 will grow
exponentially as it matures
why does this matter well it's believed
by some that one day 999 will grow
powerful enough to overthrow not only
its own monstrous siblings but the
thought to be unstoppable scarlet king
himself
not through violence or hate but through
the pure force of happiness and love
burning out the darkness and purifying
the corrupted
while the humble scp-999 rarely
outshines its frightening competitors to
those truly in the know 999 is one of
the most powerful and valuable scps in
existence
and may be the greatest asset in the
foundation's arsenal for the war against
dangerous anomalous activity after all
what could strike more fear into their
hearts than the knowledge that it might
be love rather than firepower that
finally dethrones the scarlet king
and for the knowledge that it may one
day save everything we know from a fate
so much worse than death with nothing
but affection for everyone and
everything it's worth offering thanks to
the little orange blob or at least an
extra pack of m ms before bedtime